make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I don't how many of you guys
have been tracking this but Donnie Cates
he went on Twitter a little while ago
and said that absolute carnage was
supposed to be like the definitive
carnage story right like the greatest
carnage story ever told and I believed
him because like like with his one on on
venom like everything he's done on venom
it's been nothing short of spectacular
uh and the way this first part ends I'm
excited to see what happens but for
those of you guys who are who are kind
of jumping into this for the first time
a couple things I would suggest here the
first is to go back and watch our videos
on venom and and we'll have like Ohio of
all the videos down in the description
we'll probably a full story video out of
it so you kind of have your caught up on
essentially everything but then we'll
also then also suggest you guys watch my
video on carnage explained then went
between those two things you can get
caught up
I did call carnage venom a couple times
but people knew what I meant so it's all
good but uh but yeah so this is this is
this is this is amazing now here's the
cool thing about absolute carnage if you
choose not to do that to really get
caught up on on venom to really get
caught up on that the history of carnage
you can still kind of go into this and
be okay I think it'd be better knowing
all that stuff but you know you could
still be okay because in true Donny
Kate's fashion uh we get this sort of
explanation of things that have happened
up to this point right so basically we
get this idea that at one point in time
in the very early days of this universe
right before there was any real life in
it and all you really have with the
Celestials and presumably after they won
their war with the aspirins you had that
you had no Lola symbiote God now of
course as we were told in the the first
run of venom of the first volume of
venom then no the symbiote God was this
being that was just sort of out there
right you know kind of existed in this
void this little pocket space inside the
universe created these symbiotes to
essentially serve as his agents tried to
kind of spread his influence and chaos
throughout the universe now once he was
finally defeated once this major battle
took place and he was finally locked
away this is what nany keeps kind of
ties in to what Brian Michael Bendis did
right because if you go back and you
read guardians of the galaxy by Brian
Michael Bendis he introduces the planet
of the symbiotes this idea that the
Venom symbiote that that runs around
earth originates from the this
particular planet of the clintus that's
their actual name he said that the name
of the symbiote is called the Clint are
dead
originated from that planet where we had
previously to just just believed this is
where the Soviets were and according to
Brian Michael Bendis that the symbiotes
basically existed it's like space
Knights and then they would bond
themselves to a host and they would go
on to perform great deeds that if
something like the Venom symbiote bonded
someone to someone like Eddie Brock who
was filled with anger and wrath that he
would twist the symbian it would warp
its beyond it would be honest original
purpose and it would essentially become
a bad guy
what Donnie Cates is ga'head got back
him down as he had said that's not
necessarily true
now the symbiotes were created out of
evil and the planet of the symbiotes is
as much a prison as it is a location in
the sims that once no was defeated he
was locked away inside of his own planet
or I guess inside this planet of the
symbionts and the planet itself is just
a giant ball of symbiotes that exists
out there in the universe somewhere and
so once he was defeated they kind of
began changing their tune essentially
became good guys and willingly locked
him away as best they could now the
issue at this this is kind of one of the
cool things that that Donnie Cates goes
into is if you go back and you look at
the the history of venom and the various
symbiote so like toxin carnage so on and
so forth shrieking and whatnot you had
this idea where whenever a symbiote left
an existing host and then went to a new
host they would basically maintain
information about their previous host
right it's one of the ways that the
venom Stimme was able to dodge
spider-man's spider-sense right like
spider-man was the first one to hold a
symbian and then cast it off at the
advice of Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four and so when it left him it felt
betrayed and then turned bonded itself
to Eddie Brock who has already pissed
off a Peter for costing him his job but
it took the knowledge of spider-man with
him right so like the knowledge of
Peters identity the knowledge of
spider-man's spider-sense and how it
functions and how to get around it
that's one of the reasons why venom was
so capable and so dangerous back in the
day and so the result is that what
Donnie Cates is kind of building on here
is saying that like every time a
symbiote leaves a person that it leaves
a little imprint of itself a tiny little
bit of itself now again this is existing
knowledge this really isn't anything
that Donnie Cates has built off of or I
guess really created out of his out of
his pocket
what Donnie Cates did is he came back
and he said these little code X's these
little itty bitty symbian imprints that
are left on a person's DNA if they're
all brought together they can be used
for the purpose of waking up Knoll on
the simia planet and then bringing
him back to life kind of resurrecting
him and that really seems to be the
motivation or at least one of the big
motivations behind the the carnage cult
now what what Donnie kaise is kind of
been tinkering with kind of annoying
with is this idea that Cletus Kasady
wants to resurrect null for the purpose
of killing him and taking this place
taking all of his power and then
controlling all the symbionts across the
universe and to be honest
carnage becoming God seems pretty insane
but that's really what happens here
right like carnage essentially becomes
God in this in this this this bit and
and this was kind of nuts is because
what it does is it switches over to over
to Eddie Brock now Eddie Brock is really
kind of recounting all this stuff right
like saying all these different things
and talking directly to Dylan now again
and our first volume we learned about
the character of Dylan we learned that
Dylan is actually the son of Eddie Brock
but Eddie's basically let Dylan to
believe he's simply his brother and this
is just because of the fact that that
Dylan is a son that Eddie never knew he
had right that was just kind of dropped
off at his father's house by a woman he
was with at one point he ultimately
ended up taking her own life but because
of the fact that his father was so
abusive and he wanted to get him out of
it I'd wanted to get him away from that
from that life and have him live a
normal life the downside of this is that
as they're making their way in New York
City suddenly like all these different
you know digital billboards are met with
like these wanted posters for Eddie
Brock himself and so like the whole
world is aware of who he is the whole
world is aware that like he's a
dangerous man that needs to be needs to
be captured now this is a cool thing
here because when this happens you
basically have Cletus Kasady who kind of
pops out of nowhere and then sends Eddie
and Dylan flying over into the really
unlike the way of this oncoming subway
train now this is one of the cool things
here is because when any was talking to
Dylan about who venom was I'm sorry who
carnage was then Dylan was kind of like
you know the eyes and ears are like the
new person right like the new reader he
was kind of a new reader in the story in
the sense that people who were just
jumping onto this don't really know the
history of Congress they don't really
know the legacy of carnage they don't
really know the madness that came with
Cletus Kasady
the willful abandonment right like like
just just murdering with abandoned all
these different people that he came
across for no other reason than the fact
that he could but it wasn't like he was
trying to become some super criminal to
amass great wealth or to attain absolute
power and he did all these things
because he just wanted to because he
just wanted to arbitrarily take people
out that was the kind of that's the kind
villain that Eddie's talking about right
now and that's again a villain that's
one of these we talked about in our
video on carnage explained it's one of
the kind of villains that you never
really see a villain who just shows up
and just arbitrarily takes people out
for no real reason whatsoever aside from
the fact that it's a nihilist and it
just loves to it loves madness and
carnage it loves its own namesake and so
again like what we end up finding out
here is that where Eddie and Dylan were
running away from some man in a suit
that where where Cletus Kasady was the
one who pushed him in front of the Train
the man in the suit was actually the
Venom symbiote now those you guys were
kind of playing catch-up here there came
a point during their first fight with
what was essentially this giant dragon
it's this really old Grendel suit it
wasn't really no the symbiote got
himself so much is like a facsimile of
know kind of like a taste of what would
happen if nul ever came back in like
full and true form not really as
powerful as he could be but certainly
powerful enough to like wreak havoc in
the city of New York and of course that
story culminated with Eddie Brock
grabbing the Venom symbiote and because
fire is a weakness of the symbionts
pushing knoll or at least his facsimile
of null into a furnace but also
seemingly killing the the venom Samiha
in the process and so the result was
that they were they were separated for
for an amount of time now following this
what you had were basically two stories
being told about Eddie Brock and then
one about the Venom symbiote the simian
itself got its story in the war of
realms Friday was basically dealing with
everything with Malekith and so on and
so forth Malekith stark magic which
we're talking about here in a second but
then you basically had the story of
Eddie trying to make his way and figure
himself out and that was one of the cool
things about this is because when when
the van of items to be it shows back up
and wants to bond itself to Eddie the
response of Eddie is no I don't want to
like I don't want to go back to this
life again and that's an important thing
because when Eddie first got the Venom
symbiote he saw it as a tool to be used
to defeat Peter Parker aka spider-man
for crossing him everything he was
hell-bent on revenge and anger and that
was basically it
and then you started running into these
stories where Eddie brought Eddie Brock
began to sort of change his tune where
he began began to become like a
different kind of care he became
anti-venom for a little while
he began has basically become like a
good guy almost like the the reformation
of Flash Thompson right the high school
bully of Peter Parker who lost his legs
in the military and went on to become
agent venom it's a it's a cool thing in
this scenario because what Eddie Brock
is discovered
the thing that really is the reader we
kind of always knew but any was never
really able to figure out for himself
that he's highly capable that he's a
very very capable person
now the guilt of Eddie's past life the
idea that he and his friends had hit a
kid when they were younger his father
got him off these are the kind of things
that have sort of driven him that that
kind of made him the villain but the
idea of coming back in trying to reform
trying to be a better person means
casting off that past part of his life
which includes venom being able to
settle down being able to raise his son
and to have some small measure of peace
is the guiding force behind Eddie the
problem with this is now carnage is back
and this is no small thing because when
carnage arrives here like all hell
begins to break loose right because
you're talking about about Cletus Kasady
who for all in terms of purposes should
basically be dead be toting the power of
one of the original symbionts as it was
created by by null the symbiote God
basically meaning it's more powerful
than Eddie Brock it's more powerful than
venom so this this is one of the cool
things is that interesting you because
is it's sort of a tribute of sorts at
least in the first part I mean not not
fully on in terms of the entirety of the
story but in this first part here it's a
tip of the half to maximum carnage when
the carnage symbiote bonded to Cletus
Kasady on the blood level and he became
just way more powerful than been both
Eddie Brock and spider-man uh he was a
force to be reckoned with we're
essentially dealing with the same
concept except amplified even further
it's the symbiote joined to - Cletus
Kasady on the blood level but it's a
more powerful symbiote than Amon the
than both venom and and really like any
other one that we see out there right
now this is an exceedingly dangerous
incredibly powerful carnage just running
around out there right now and like it
really shows because he basically one
punches Eddie Brock he punches him in
the face he breaks his orbital bone his
brain is hemorrhaging I mean in like one
fell swoop Eddie Brock's been taken out
that's the kind of carnage that we're
dealing with back in the day it was
really more like Carnage's durability
right his ability to create all kinds of
different sharp appendages and someone
and so forth and his insanity that made
him almost unpredictable that's really
what made him so is such a such a huge
force back in the day and this one it's
just like the sheer force of the
symbiote he wields the power he
possesses is enough to like take out
Eddie Brock in one hit and so what Eddie
does is respond in kind
doing the
only thing he can do grabbing elect
grabbing the electrical lines of the of
where the subway train was and then
grabbing Venna grabbing a carnage and
then just electrocuting the piss out of
him and basically it destroys the
carnage symbiote you know in the interim
but all it really does is it's really
just kind of like temporarily send it
into chaos and that's basically it
it's a stopgap measure and Eddie knows
this right Eddie knows this is a stopgap
measure he knows there's no real way as
far as he's aware to defeat carnage in
the traditional sense and again that
makes sense because in the maximum
carnage storyline it really took the
combined efforts of spider-man and venom
to pull it off now even the first time a
met before maximum carnage it took the
combined efforts of Veneman and Peter
Parker you know spider-man to defeat
this guy and so again we're dealing with
a super amped up very powerful version
of carnage and so as a result of this
the venom Samiha shuts down the mind of
Eddie Brock puts him in a coma to a
catatonic state while he basically heals
his body and then takes him to the only
place the one place where they can get
any real measure of help and it's a cool
thing because we all knew this was
coming we all knew it was only a matter
of time before this happened what ends
up happening here is that once they
arrived to list location the symbiote
wakes up Eddie Brock and they knock on
the door of an apartment and when this
happens somebody answers the door and
that's what we end up finding out the
person the Venom symbiote took Eddie
Brock to the only real person he'd be
able to get any help from in this
situation or the very least the only one
who would listen to him is Peter Parker
spider-man okay uh so we are getting
back into absolute carnage and and
here's the thing so the original
absolute carnage ER against the first
issue was split into three parts and for
the most part it looks like it's what
they're gonna do from the issues going
forward I have not read the the physical
issue number two yet so I'm not
interested sure I've been on vacation
for the last week drought of the Pacific
Coast Highway which was amazing but kind
of getting into this one then we'll
actually do the third part of the first
issue later on this week so what kind of
what kind of wrap everything up in the
last one it was really like the return
of Cletus Kasady right and that was a
big thing that was that was people were
really expecting and had really been
told to us in the events leading up to
absolute carnage it was kind of the big
the the big take away from it right I
mean Cletus Kasady is the original
carnage he's a fan favorite has been for
a long long time and is one of those
things where unless as Cletus Kasady
playing carnage people are kind of
you know kind of iffy about it the only
real exception to that is Norman Osborn
when he was the red goblin that was
really really cool actually talked about
him here in a little bit but what this
does is it picks up with Peter and Eddie
Brock and then of course you know
Eddie's Eddie's son Dylan all basically
getting yet getting together in Converse
and the reason why is because again when
it came to carnage first popping up of
course it was fears it was spider-man
and venom who fought him and then you
went into maximum carnage which was
spider-man and venom fighting and
fighting him again and and the idea is
that with someone like carnage it takes
the two of them to succeed because
carnage is so incredibly strong right
the fact that the symbiote is bonded to
the blood of Cletus Kasady is what
really amps up his powers beyond what
you normally see with like venom or
anybody along those lines anybody that
normally wears the symbian and so it
makes sense that you would see any kind
of team up with spider-man now for a
long time carnage fans and really
longtime spider-man fans this connor has
to be a bit of a hit into the nostalgia
feels right it's kind of like man this
is this is kind of this kind of feels a
little bit old-school and that's why
it's kind of a cool moment is because a
lot of things have transpired in the
life of Eddie Brock that Peter Parker
didn't know about for example Peter
Parker does not know that Dylan is the
son of Eddie now of course when Eddie
sends doing away says hey look go do
something else just don't be here it's
adult talking time you guys all remember
that for when you were kids it's a
chance for Eddie to basically sort of
kind of let his guard down right and
just sort of let the whole thing kind of
be out there and say hey look like he's
my kid and this isn't really even about
me it really it's not even really about
me stopping carnage it's about like
stopping here to make sure that my kids
safe right because if carnage gets his
hands on my kid he'll kill him and it's
really just protecting people outside of
myself and that's why it's a really
important thing right because Eddie's
been a bad guy he's been a good guy he's
been a victim of circumstance spider-man
seen a lot of things transpire with the
character of Eddie and this is kind of
the newest take for his character
insofar as he's out there and coping
with a few things and it works and it is
really cool to see because it kind of
makes spider-man a little softer to him
and say okay you know I guess I can kind
of get where you're coming from but then
suddenly they're met with a news
broadcast and there's this mass grave
that was essentially dug up out in the
middle of nowhere it initially is kind
of like whatever man nobody wants to see
this they turn it off Eddie Brock starts
freaking out spider-man's like what the
heck is going on and he was like
everybody who's ever been a symbian is
buried out there like they're there in
that mass grave right and that's one of
the big things that we recall from what
we've been told both during the pre loot
stories to to absolute carnage and by
the interviews that the Donnie Cates has
done himself that you have this
circumstance or Cleatus
he is basically going around and
grabbing what are called these code X's
right these little codices pieces and is
designed to basically like kind of
recreate the whole right it sort of been
that way ever since Noll popped up in
the sense that like when Noah was there
it was he was the guy that created all
the symbiotes they function as a
cohesive unit and following his defeat
they've kind of been separated ever
since and as the current symbiote
basically grabbing all these different
iterations of either itself or venom
Emmons combining them all into a
singular unit which will amplify his
power even further and then presumably
try to take on Nolan and you know
destroy Nolan to become like god of the
symbionts which makes sense to be
actually really cool to see if carnage
like took over all the symbionts and
became their new god ah but it's a cool
little thing here because what you get
is this revelation you know where Eddie
is freaking out he's kind of panicking
the big thing to really come out of this
is he saying like Annie's body is buried
out there somewhere now for those of you
guys who have not been keeping up with
Donnie cases run on venom and really
aren't longtime readers of of the
spider-man comics the person he's
referring to Annie she's actually a
character that appeared back in amazing
spider-man 375 in 1990 93 and this is
Annie Wayne now any weighing is actually
the second person to host the Venom
symbiote and in fact she used the name
she venom at one point in time but she's
also the biological mother of Dillon and
for those and the reason why I say
Donnie Cates run is because in the early
part of his run when he basically got
the introduction of Dillon's character
it was amy was pregnant with Eddie
Brock's son she didn't want Eddie to
know because of course he was venom he
was a bad guy at the time and so she
basically gave birth to the kid dropped
it off at the father of Eddie Brock's
house and then just kind of left it
there and then originally she went and
jumped off a bridge and died but the
idea behind it is that basically his
ex-wife is out there and that she can
basically be be used by carnage to
become one of his henchmen or what have
you it's kind of a crushing thing and
that's reason why any sword starts to
freak out now again this is one of the
cool things about his character because
if we're talking about like 1990s venom
lethal protector you know and weird is
sort of like he's doing his own thing
and being a bad guy he probably wouldn't
have cared about that but the nature of
Eddie is that over the years his
characters become a lot more dynamic has
become a lot more intrigue and he's
grown a lot in terms of what writers
have done with him and in kind of how he
views the world but it's a cool thing
because it's kind of like okay so like
the notion that Eddie Brock has a lot
more on the line than Carnage's back
let's fight him it's cool is it
something that I'm really really digging
about the way his characters being
handled that's why I love the venom run
from from Donnie Cates so much because
it's almost kind of seems to be more
focused on Eddie than it is on the
symbiote itself right I mean the Venom's
to be a super popular that kind of makes
since and so in response to this with
everything kind of popping off the way
that it is there something burglars at
busting and spotting man takes care of
him quick fast and in a hurry and it's
kinda like okay you know cool whatever
and then he's like we need to go see a
guy they could basically help us get
this stuff sorted out and of course
that's when they basically go back to
rush Strickland's safe house of course
rush Strickland being one of the
previous hosts for the Grendel's Indians
um kind of the precursor to venom
basically and then of course they're
essentially talking with the maker now
this is kind of a cool moment because
the idea of the maker meeting spider-man
is a cool little thing right because in
Marvel they never actually met before
like they've never really met I mean
even with spider-man there during the
events of secret Wars like his dealings
were with like Miles Morales and with
with the molecule man Owen Reese and of
course you know Reed Richards from his
main universe but like that was
basically it
you know the maker kind of being out
there and and being part of the equation
and everything it's kind of a cool
little moment here because you know when
you have Eddie show up here one of the
things we end up learning is again the
mysterious benefactors the people that
that maker works for that we don't
really know who they are it's basically
like hey they had a lot of interest in
using the carnage symbiote or even the
venom Sumida itself they want to know
how to like use them for their own ends
either weaponizing them using them for
new technologies whatever the case
happens to be but like they've been
working on a means to extract the
symbiote from individuals already and
then do it in a way that's saved that
can preserve the life of the person who
was infected and so was kind of a cool
moment here because when this happens
you basically have like Spider Man
talking to him but then also bringing in
his godson Normie as born now Normie
Normie Osborn okay this characters
interesting um he almost kind of has the
Franklin Richards effect in the sense
that like he first popped up back in
like amazing spider-man 2 85 and then
like nobody really did anything with him
after that not for a long time Norman
Osborn really had his big moment during
the red goblin storyline and we never
actually covered that the go down
swinging storyline we never actually
covered that I feel like we should if
for no other reason than the fact that
like it ties in pretty neatly with
absolute carnage but basically Norman
Osborn is the son of Harry and the
grandson of Norman so Norman Osborn as
most of you guys know is the Green
Goblin right in the big moment he had
over the course of the entire publishing
career was throwing Gwen Stacy off the
bridge and in certain circles there's
still a debate that goes on over who
actually killed Gwen Stacy if it was the
Green Goblin who killed her before
spider-man got there or if he was
spider-man shooting his webbing into her
foot and they're like her neck snapped
right because it goes both ways there's
actually there's an actual onomatopoeia
in the comic it says like snap
like her next snaps and then in the same
comic you know the Green Goblin is like
I killed her before you got here so
there's fans I kind of go either way and
really kind of the argument rages still
to this day ah but following that really
like the the next big moment I would say
in the history of Green Goblin like the
really huge landmark kind of character
shifting moment came during the events
of Dark Reign right you come out of
Secret Invasion Tony Stark is kicked out
as director of shield after the fact
that Neil Scrolls have been replacing
humans and various superheroes and Tony
Stark didn't know um and so he's
replaced with Norman Osborn who had a
key piece of information that turned the
tide of the secret invasion war that
basically led to humanity winning and so
he dismantle shield he basically creates
hammer and he goes forward doing villain
things because he's a bad guy and then
tries to like basically conquer the
United States and eventually the world
now ultimately he's defeated he's thrown
in jail and then along the way the Green
Goblin kind of bothers him a little bit
kind of harasses him and then ultimately
he recalls hammer makes his escape and
then he was kind of free-floating after
that and then you go into basically the
red goblin story which is kind of a kind
of an attempt to bring Norman Osborn
back but then modify it right so given
the current symbiote and basically
become a combination of the Green Goblin
and and the carnage symbiote which is
basically red Goblin I mean it was a
cool thing but during that story what he
did is he's actually kidnapped Normie
and then basically you know put a piece
of the of the symbiote into Norman
Osborn and then turned him into what was
called goblin child and it was kind of a
cool little little segment it was a
crowd of those a culo thing it didn't
really last long enough to see where it
went just because of the fact that
you're coming up on the end of dance
lots run and that basically went into
the new era of Spider Man with Nick
Spencer but it was a cool little thing
it was it was a cool moment and a cool
bit of storytelling but that really
Norman Osborn's just kind of been in
Ravencroft ever since when he never
since the events of the red goblin story
when he was defeated he's just kind of
been locked up and in prison but that's
why Normie Osborn is here is because
because of the fact that he held the
Simeon at one point that codex is there
now remember the codex is really dotty
Kate's way of explaining how it is that
the Venom symbiote could leave Peter
Parker and then go to Eddie Brock and
still remember everything about Peter
Parker right it plants a little piece of
itself a little memory a little little
tiny knowledge fragment a little nugget
of information in Peter leaves it there
and it always happens from one host to
the next as was basically carnage going
around and trying to take each one of
those individuals into himself and
capture their codex by default and so
initially the idea of the maker is well
if this kids been exposed to the Codex
then let's basically take a blood sample
and see if we can't find a way to you
know
find a weakness or you know what this
codex means and if we can use
information there to take out carnage of
course the response the Spider Man is
absolutely not I'm not gonna let some
crazy guy who is an alternate reality
version of Reed Richards take a blood
sample off of my godson because I don't
know what this guy's gonna do with it if
he's gonna create like a thousand clones
of this kid kudos like this guy's kind
of bonkers at in reality he's right the
maker is kind of crazy but as a result
of this the makers like well then fine
give me somebody else give me anybody
else out there that you know of off the
top of your head right now who's held
the venom or the carnage symbiote and
then bring them here and there's only
one person that these two guys are aware
of there's only one individual that
these two guys know that they could
basically find locate bring them back
and then use that person as it means to
achieve this goal and we'll find out in
the next video okay so the power supply
for my EGP you fried my macbook pro had
a hardware failure that I had to take it
in and have it shipped off for repair
everything's failing in my home right
now what's going on guys this is Rob and
we're covering part three of absolute
carnage in part two really parts of 1
and part 2 because remember part like
the the first issue split into three
parts the first two parts it was
basically panic mode right it was the
idea that Cletus Kasady had essentially
returned now the way that Donnie Cates
had written this is a Cletus Kasady had
been coming back for a while it's just
that right now Eddie Brock just realized
what was really happening right he just
realized they liked Cletus Kasady he
made his return and I love the way the
Donnie Cates wrote that right because
before the person who's kind of getting
into carnage and doesn't really know
anything about the character it's like
cool a new symbian for people who are
familiar with with carnage it's like
cool in old symbian and a lot of people
are going to die but it's one of these
things were kind of like your dedication
and and your sort of time spent with the
character of Cletus Kasady over the
years it's kind of rewarded right
because like this is the return this is
like the joke if the Joker got the venom
Samiha right like a crazy person becomes
venom and then like loses their minds
but the idea behind this is that we're
basically dealing with with them going
and grabbing Norman Osborn now we talked
about this in the last video and what
kind of refresh it a little bit for
those of you guys who are you know kind
of coming into this so if you're
watching the full story version of this
what kind of be repeating ourselves for
a second but the idea behind Norman
Osborn becoming the the really the red
goblin I the carnage and the the Goblin
concept was to kind of try to
reinvigorate Norman Osborn right to kind
of like give him a new status quo after
the events of Dark Reign INRI
you don't really need to write there are
some villains out there in the realm of
comic books the Joker
Lex Luthor characters like like Norman
Osborn who's probably well he's not
certainly the most iconic spider-man
villain I'd say he's probably the most
important and so what they did is that
his Marvel basically said let's give him
the card symbiote and then in turn have
him bring back the Green Goblin so he
basically becomes the red goblin and it
was really popular for a little while
right like it's one of the more popular
stories involving the various symbiotes
I would say it's more popular because it
involves a symbiote as opposed to just
the Green Goblin himself but again he's
a legacy villain right so it's one less
thing you'd have to really change all
that often what you end up having here
is spider-man and you have venom who
basically race off to grab Norman Osborn
and this is kind of an important thing
here right because with Norman Osborn as
the red goblin I wouldn't say he pushed
the symbiote to new heights by virtue of
like his intelligence of so on and so
forth it was really more like merging
with the Green Goblin and the Venom
symbiote that kind of pushed to new
heights but Norman Osborn is not an
unintelligent guy and the real question
the idea behind this is that with venom
really realizing what's going on and
this idea that Cletus Kasady is running
around and tracking these code X's right
like trying to kill the various
individuals who have been the simian
host the question is we kind of have to
save Norman Osborn now it's interesting
here because on the surface you would
say well then let him die right I just
let Norman Osborn die and it's one of
those funny things because it's really
more of the moral quagmire of venom and
spider-man what kind of superheroes
would they be if they just let Norman
Osborn die but I mean that's kind of the
issue that you run into here what kind
of heroes would they be if they let this
guy die and that was basically the end
of it and so again it's kind of
intriguing because in the midst of all
this suddenly you end up having
spider-man who goes nuts and this is one
of the more important things that Donnie
Cates is doing here again we talked
about this in the first couple parts and
it bears repeating here but the idea is
that in in years past right going all
the way back to like even you gotta like
David McLean II is um original like
venom lethal protector but like you go
all the way back to like when when
carnage was first introduced and even
before that when venom was introduced
and all the various simius between them
right like scream and and riot and all
those guys the way this always worked
and was kind of etched in stone by venom
is that when a person becomes a host the
symbiote can leap right like if by you
know by whatever manner and whatever
means if the symbiote leaves the sumia
takes memories of that person with them
right so that was the case of venom
knowing the identity of Peter Parker the
venoms to being here bonded to Peter it
was cast off a lemon spider-man 45 and
then it bonded itself to Eddie Brock
taking the knowledge of Peter
the identity of spider-man win it and so
the reason why that's important is
because what this does is it basically
allows Donnie Cates to build on that
concept and say actually what happens is
for all those individuals who have been
a host of the carnage symbiote it leaves
back at least behind itself a kind of
sample right like a kind of little
genetic code that the the current Samiha
that Cletus Kasady can tap into now the
big question to ask here this is kind of
a big thing to come out of this kin
venom do the same thing can they tap
into and can they basically control the
minds of other individuals by using that
genetic code one of the other big
changes that Donnie Cates is making here
is Carnage's ability to spawn more
symbionts what Cletus is doing here is
basically creating these little mini
pots and then they're forcing themselves
into various prisons going into the
bodies of those particular prisoners and
then basically creating more symbionts
so to speak now it's kind of interesting
here because these aren't really carnage
symbionts in the traditional sense which
is to say they're not really like
duplicates of himself they're really
more akin to like children and that's
why this is cool because if you look at
this it looks like you literally have
Donna Cates building up this army of
soldiers more or less for carnage who in
turn can allow him to try to defeat null
the symbiote god that's kind of where I
hope this is going to but you end up
having carnage in spider-man and venom
all teaming up to face off against null
and then like truly and successfully to
feed him like it'd be kind of cool but
it's kind of one of these funny things
because as that goes off you know as
this begins to go down you end up having
a course a sound system is triggered and
then with the sound system being
triggered as we know with with symbionts
they hate like loud sonic vibrations and
so where Eddie goes to take them out it
allows him and Peter to basically team
up and try to face off against the
forces of carnage but that's where
things begin to go awry because at the
outset you simply expect it to just be
Cletus Kasady right now you expect it to
just be him and go walking in because
the reality of this is that you go back
and you look at like maximum carnage the
maximum carnage storyline you go back
and look at the time that like Eddie and
and spider-man first fought venom before
maximum carnage and you're talking about
a simian out there that's stronger than
the two of them right so Cletus Kasady
alone would be enough to overtake and to
basically defeat spider-man and venom
and so this is designed to illustrate
one or two things or possibly both the
first is that it's designed to basically
show that like all these different
characters are designed to show up and
basically cause absolute pandemonium
right like bolstering the numbers of
carnage
forces the other half of this and this
is what I think is actually a little
more interesting is that Cletus Kasady
is getting arrogant I can send my forces
forward and have them do it for me now
in reality if Cletus Kasady is getting
carried away for themselves and if he's
being arrogant Dennis with good reason
because you basically have like all
these different forces that are pretty
much overtaking venom and spider-man and
they're doing a pretty darn good job at
it right I mean that's kind of the
nature of things is you're talking about
these exceedingly strong and powerful
versions of carnage really like more of
the Grendel's than anything else they're
just kind of ripping things up and so in
the midst of all this or Peter kind of
get to see no throne to you know thrown
to the side he's met by the arrival of
Cletus and that's when things really get
scary right because Cletus is a man
without reason and that's what makes
Cletus so dangerous is because of the
fact that he's a believer but he
believes that what he's doing is right
he believes that what he's doing is the
correct thing to do and you can't sway
him from that belief he's a guy that
just cannot be changed and so what
happens when you give a person who
cannot be changed the power to force
change onto other people they're gonna
do exactly that they're going to
basically create a litany of reasons for
why you're wrong and then force their
entire perspective on D right so either
you can reject it or you can accept it
but you're not going to be able to get
them to change what it is that they're
doing and that's what's so cool about
this is because you basically have like
like venom fighting off against Peter
and it's one of these cool little
moments because when that happens then
I'm actually sort of chastised as Peter
for a second and says stop being clever
stop being funny stop cracking jokes
this is time for business and that's an
important thing but one of the things
that Dan Slott established during the
original spider-man renew your vows as
part of Secret Wars is there's a reason
why Peter does this but there's no
reason to do it here one of the big
questions people had all the time for it
for years and years and years Peter
would crack jokes in the middle of
fights and and people always sort of
attributed that to the fact that Peter
was just a character who would joke
around but there's a reason for why
Peter does this so really it took
decades to get to the point we could
actually get an explanation to it but
during the original renew your vows Dan
Slott stated that the reason why Peter
does that is it because it throws his
enemy off right it frustrates is enemy
and makes them angry because the enemy
believes Peter doesn't respect them
right like I'm not I'm not taking this
fight seriously because you're not
really anybody to worry about this is
business as usual and you're of no real
concern to me that's the message Peter
puts off right the I had the other idea
is to kind of keep things loose and they
keep Peter from getting carried away
keep him from getting like super
overexcited and and to kind of keep him
grounded and in
moment but it's as much to like screw
with the other guy the issue with this
is that with Cletus Kasady
that don't work that dog don't bark
right because Cletus Kasady doesn't take
the bait that's the nature of Cletus
Kasady is about as crazy you know I'm
not really as crazy he's crazier than
spider-man so like cracking jokes going
on about nonsense it doesn't really work
and that's why Ivanova says it's not the
time to be clever it's not the time to
be funny it's not the time to like crack
jokes and be your usual self this is the
time to be serious because if we're not
we could die here today and Peter knows
that but venom doesn't know that Peter
knows that it's just Peters way of doing
things it's kind of how Peter is and so
following this the two of them are
basically like knocked out of the cell
you know sent flying out into the
hallway and that's when Peter basically
begs for carnage not to kill Norman
Osborn and that's what he says I'm not
here to kill him I'm here to add him to
my forces it's literally carnage
absorbing Norman Osborn into himself and
basically turning Norman Osborn into one
of his various henchmen now Norman
Osborn does not have the Grendel
insignia on his forehead and the
indication here is that Norman Osborn is
something wholly new like it may be that
he's something wholly different and
wholly new probably not he's probably
just just like all the other ones right
there's nothing really special about him
but I have a hard time believing Donnie
Cates wouldn't do it wouldn't have him
depicted in this manner if he wasn't
different from everybody else so I'm
really excited I'm really curious to see
where it goes okay so we are a little
behind on absolute carnage and you would
think that we would be caught up right
like you think we would have it all
caught up and everything because I
really love this event but I took a
vacation all last week except for like
two days in one of those audios was
already just kind of out there so now
we're actually getting back into the
thick of things
brightly actually getting back into the
meat and potatoes of recording a lot of
you guys are probably also wondering why
I haven't done full story videos
recently I'm actually saving them
towards the end of the year and I'm just
gonna kind of like do a month where I
just dump a whole bunch of full story
videos from what we've done so far and
just kind of go from there right so
absolute carnage will probably come out
in like November and it'll be like a few
others here and there so yes absolute
carnage part two okay so what Donnie
Cates is basically written so far is
this story where things are in dire
straits right I mean and here's a funny
thing about absolute carnage is in this
issue and this this really technically
it's a second issue although it's like
the fourth part more or less it almost
kind of feels like spider-verse
meets like carnage I mean we're not
dealing with multiversal versions of
carnage but it does feel like that and
so far as anybody who's ever held a
symbiote is this
we being tracked down by carnage and
being consumed now this is one of the
things that I kind of wanted to toy with
in the last video and we kind of want to
bring to light in this one is that
really Norman Osborn is not fully under
the control of carnage right and it's
something that a few of you guys pointed
out in the last in the comments last
video for those individuals who were
totally under the control of carnage
they have that little spinning us neo
spiral thing on their face for Norman
Osborn he doesn't have that now why he
doesn't have that is not explicitly
given to us right because looking at
this author of the top of our heads what
we've seen so far those individuals who
carnage has consumed are under his
control right but the individuals that
we've seen him consume so far at least
in the first few issues have just been
those these basically taking a portion
of himself and put it inside of them so
we don't really know at least at the
moment at least the time I'm making this
video anyway like suspend your disbelief
for a for a second but the idea behind
this is that it doesn't look like Norman
Osborn is totally under the control of
carnage and this is cool because it
allows Norman Osborn to basically
maintain himself it allows him to kind
of keep the personality that we've all
kind of come to know and love over the
years the kind of rebellious guy the guy
that like you can't tell me what to do
because what you basically have here by
virtue of Cletus Kasady and carnage is
you've got two roosters in the hen house
that's essentially what's going on and
one of them's gonna have to go that's
basically what's taking place here now
of course for spider-man and venom
fighting off against these massive
numbers of carnage forces there's no way
they can win right and it would be a
foolish measure to try and stay it would
be stupid I mean there's there really
wouldn't be any sense in it right
they're throwing away their life for
something dumb if they were to stay here
now remember spider-man does not know
all the changes that have gone on with
the venom Simmi he doesn't know
everything that's happened here and so
this is important because for any Brock
himself of course having come into
contact with null basically sort of
expanded the powers of his symbiote
which in turn granted him of course the
power of flight by use of wings
spider-man doesn't know all this stuff
right so he's kind of coming into this
thinking this is venom is I've always
known him we're standing at the top of
like you know Ravencroft asylum if we
jump off we're probably gonna be dashed
to pieces on the rocks we're screwed
we're basically gonna die and and it's
cool because Eddie Brock basically flies
them to safety now this is where the
Norman Osborn part begins to come in
because where you have you know Norman
Osborn asking the question why are we
going after them the response he's being
given by it by Cletus Kasady is well
because there's other people for us to
go after now this is kind of a cool
thing because Norman Osborn stance is
what we got to take out spider-man and
we got to take out venom because they'll
come back and they'll
just later on and in reality he's not
wrong the funny thing about this is that
they're actually looking at the same
goal from two different perspectives
right so like Norman Osborn is looking
at this from the from the perspective of
like what we saw with Dark Reign take
out the heroes right off the bat like
give them out of there as fast as you
can and there'll be nobody staying
nobody to stand against you Cletus
Kasady on the other hand seems a little
more subversive right his stance is we
won't go after them we'll just amass our
forces - such a huge amount that we
don't need to worry about them right
it's like when they come calling with
whatever forces they have it won't make
a difference
it's cool in terms of how their
approaches work because both of them
have merit now the problem with this
comes when it's venom and and Spider Man
kind of transitioning back to these
characters again what is venom in Spider
Man and it's what do we do next right
like where do we go from here because
they're both in pretty dire straits
right I mean this is basically their
worst nightmare right in a lot of
different ways it's the worst thing they
could have seen happening the most
insane character they've ever come
across bonded to one of the most
powerful symbionts in existence probably
the most powerful short of of nolza
symbiote God himself is now running amok
in the city of New York and marshaling
its forces it's pretty bad
that's this it's pretty terrible you're
talking about a crazy guy so he's
leading the show he's running the show
here and then he's creating a whole mess
of people like a whole army of people
who can avoid spider-man's spider-sense
it's the most horrifying thing ever
because at any point spider-man could
die and he'd be dead before he heard the
sound - killed him so it's one of these
crazy scenarios and now for Eddie Brock
himself things are a little bit
different the cool aspect is that
because of the fact that this is really
what Donnie Cate seemed to be seems to
be going with it he can kind of go two
different directions right but venom
himself can kind of feel the forces of
of carnage it doesn't mean he knows he
can pinpoint them exactly where they are
right like he's no Molly Walker from
heroes but it but it's one of these
things where you can kind of feel you
know feel the fact that they're out
there and they're kind of making their
way towards him so and almost kind of
seems to be an empathic thing how it is
it he picks up on that again it can kind
of go a couple different ways it can go
by way of the fact that all these forces
are being marshaled by a Grendel
symbiote which is kind of a precursor to
the the symbian of Eddie Brock and have
like the Venom's to be and all that kind
of stuff we can kind of go that route or
we can go the route that I think is a
little more interesting is that
basically carnage is spawned directly
from venom and so because carnage is
spawned directly from venom and because
carnage bonded was Cletus Kasady on the
blood level even though he's using a
Grindle symbiote it kind of seems to
carry over and it allows Eddie Brock to
basically feel the offspring
cletus kasady in the form of all these
different forces out there so it's kind
of a cool little moment here but
ultimately they end up settling on the
idea that spider-man is essentially
going to marshal the Avengers right
because remember spider-man is an
Avenger and he has been since the New
Avengers by Brian Michael Bendis it's
one of the things a lot of people tend
to forget that spider-man is kind of
easy he's out there and he does his own
superhero thing but unless you're
reading an Avengers story that involves
him being part of the team it's easy to
forget that he is a member of the team
the issue with the Avengers comics as
you usually see them is that they often
focus on the core Avengers rosters right
the ones who were there day in and day
out now again it's kind of a cool little
show by Donna Cates because in this day
and age and the age of crossovers with
Marvel it's the one question a lot of
people would ask is like why didn't
spider-man get a hold of the Avengers
right so like he nips that right in the
butt like we'll call Captain America
will call Wolverine those two guys
specifically because they dealt with a
Grendel symbian in the past and they
kind of know how to defeat them or at
least have a much better understanding
of how to face off against it the
problem is that in the middle of all
this suddenly Eddie Brock basically gets
a call from from the maker Reed Richards
from the Ultimate Universe now the idea
here is that read this this version of
read the makers con just been
safeguarding Dillon right the son of
Eddie Brock albeit Dillon doesn't know
and so one of the funny things is that
he you know literally the maker says
I've been combing through the FBI's
database here and like an weighing was
not in the body and like the mass grave
that was dug up right like she was her
herb her corpse was never there and that
was a big concern of Eddie Brock because
remember we talked about this in the
last video but an weighing was basically
his ex-wife more or less right I mean
you know it was one of these things
where Donny Cates kind of kind of threw
it in there so that she was pregnant
with Eddie's child and just we never
knew ah but it was is one of those
things where basically she was the Venom
symbiote for a little while and then
eventually I drove her crazy Eddie Brock
drove her crazy a whole bunch of things
drove her insane and she jumped off a
building into her death right like
in-between that time period that's when
Donny Cates came in and said actually
she was pregnant with Eddie rocks kid
and the result is I did that kid is here
now the issue with this is that if and
weighing having been a host for the
venom Samiha at one point did not have a
codex in her body and the question is
who has it and what the maker says is
she passed it off to Dillon now this is
a very important thing because what this
means is that a codex can leave a person
and go to someone else in reality this
is a way out for Donny Cates because
what he could do here is at the end of
the story he could basically say all the
codex all the codices are now inside
carnage and where carnage would seek to
rule as
right hand of nova symbian and kind of
bring darkness to the universe no it
would kind of be like yeah
now and then just kill Cletus Kasady
take take everything and take all the
codices to himself and then boy
everybody probably end up dying anyway
because he would be returned to full
power but the fact remains that a codex
can be passed from one person to the
next now we don't know if the codex is a
physical thing we know it's written into
a person's DNA but as we know when it
comes to offspring it's not like a mom
gives birth to a child and then all her
blood goes into the child and all her
DNA goes into the child and she loses
everything about herself it's more let's
just kind of copying her DNA and the
father's DNA into that baby and this is
kind of a combination of both and so
this creates a really interesting
scenario here because normally you would
look at that and you would say well the
codex is kind of copied from her into
into Dylan but instead it just went into
Dylan entirely so it's kind of a cool
little revelation here I mean there's a
lot you can extrapolate from these small
little things and that's why I Donnie
Cates is such a great writer because you
can bring these small little bits and
pieces into this stuff and just kind of
throw it in there now from here of
course you basically deal with Eddie
Brock facing off against like all these
carnage Grendel guys who are all running
up on him it is like as fast as they can
it's kind of chris is like a cool moment
cuz it's like Venom's last stand and so
it's pretty badass I really dig this
because here's the thing here here's the
thing all right Donnie Cates is venom
it's cool because the way he writes it I
feel like Donnie Cates writing venom is
about the most awesome he's been in a
few decades and I say that understanding
what it is that I'm saying right I mean
he was basically saying like venom
hasn't really been cool since lethal
protector by David McLean II and I would
kind of agree with that I mean there's
been some cool moments but venom himself
being cool I don't think it really
happened for a long time and I'm talking
about like when when things like
scorpion when Max the organ was venom
and stuff like that I mean I guess maybe
I guess fans of Flash Thompson of agent
venom will probably get pissed off about
that I don't really care I never really
liked agent venom all that much I was
never a huge fan of him like he was cool
and it was a cool concept but I'm
old-school Eddie Brock all the way right
like I dig Eddie Brock it has been and
so Eddie Brock is venom hasn't really
been that cool because he hasn't Leben
venom for a long time but still the fact
remains it's one of these awesome little
these little moments because what it
does is it switches over to Miles
Morales and to scorpion right now again
scorpion was a previous host for a Venom
symbiote which means that he's basically
got the Codex inside of it right I mean
you know Mac Gargan being venom that
came during Dark Reign right he was one
of the Dark Avengers or at least one of
the dark guys
the Dark Avengers with all the villains
playing good guys essentially and so
this was a cool thing because you end up
having like like Miles Morales holding
his own against all these guys now this
is an important an important thing to
talk about here because for those
individuals who are new to Miles Morales
they would look at that and they would
still see him as like the new kid on the
block and a lot of ways he is in
comparison like how long Venom's been
I've been ocular how long spider-man's
been active and how long Cletus Kasady
has been active he is kind of the new
kid on the block right even looking at
like other spider characters right like
Miguel O'Hara spider-man 2099 looking at
like Cain looking at Ben Riley but you
get a lot of those carriers who were out
there yeah I mean they've they've been
there and and they're there they've been
there for a very very long time
so really Myles is the new kid but miles
has a lot of experience under his belt
that really helps him catch up right the
entire events of spider-verse right
fighting off against the inheritors it's
PI 2 versus 2 I mean there's all these
these cool moments these cool story
lines that he's been a part of where
he's faced off against some pretty heavy
hitters so grabbing a lot of experience
rolling it under his belt the entirety
of Secret Wars by by Jonathan Hickman
all the events that transpired in there
so he's grown up pretty fast and gained
a pretty solid understanding of what
he's capable of and so again using his
his shock he had all that kind of cool
stuff facing off against these guys he's
able to hold his own to a degree more
than you would expect which is kind of
cool for a little mile so go miles you
got it little buddy but he's he's doing
a great job but uh but of course Mac
Gargan tries to escape and venom forces
him back in again the issue is that as
soon as that happens they're basically
met by by carnage who's like okay cool
smash this guy up and drag him and and
I'm sorry bye-bye actually it looks like
Norman Osborn to be honest doesn't
really have the thing on his head but
they basically end up snatching him up
and of course they manage to impale him
but of course he ends up getting away
when miles goes to attack and this is
one of the crappy things that goes on
here because what takes place is that
where this is revealed to be Cletus
Kasady and it is actually him going
through and and trying to capture Mac
Gargan we end up having him capture
Miles Morales and this is kind of a big
moment because we haven't really seen
him capture a spider character yet and
so that's why it's really seems to feel
a lot like spider-verse because it kind
of seems you moving in the realm of the
inheritors the question to ask here is
what will Miles do in relation to
beefing up the power of like you know
Carnage's forces like will it kind of be
spread all throughout they're more
religious beefed up the power of colitas
Cassady how's all this going to work the
other thing to bear in mind here is that
there's a lot of information the miles
has a lot of places to get to right like
the
the what is it the the spider the spider
folks out there the what was the
multiversal spider-man team I don't know
what they were called nobody read it
some Marvel canceled it but uh I guess
I'm not alone in that regard but but
nonetheless there's a lot of cool things
that could come out of this a lot of
information that could be extrapolated
and could be extracted by cletus kasady
from Miles Morales on how to defeat
these various characters on how to take
all them out as far as I'm aware my
house does not know that Eddie Brock has
a son Dillon and so as far as were aware
I mean I know that the carnage kind of
knows but there's nothing to lead
carnage to know that that Dillon is one
with the Codex right I mean we don't
really know that yet I mean I guess he's
just kind of tracking down inherently
but still it's a cool moment right I
mean because what this does is he goes
into the one shot of Miles Morales being
taken over by carnage is a cool moment
like it's the story's pretty solid like
I'm really digging it so far okay so
absolute carnage just keeps getting
better and better this story just keeps
getting ridiculously good it's
absolutely insane and what this one does
is it gives us like one of the coolest
moments ever in the history of of venom
and and all that good stuff now
initially this picks up after issue
number two I'm still debating on whether
or not I'm gonna cover the tie-ins I'm
not a hundred percent sure that's one of
the reasons why I'm doing this issue by
issue is because if we decide to cover
the tie-ins
we can do that later on just by like you
know or at least I've done like covering
that video and then throwing into the
playlist and then just kind of being
done with it but it is cool because this
comes in the aftermath of basically
carnage taking over Miles Morales now
remember carnage is going after
everybody who has in any former fashion
either come in contact with a with a
symbiote which grants them a codex
meaning that the semi it leaves its DNA
behind or a person that he could add to
their rank add to his range in order to
basically bolster his abilities and use
them as a means to achieve his goal
right so it's really kind of - full
technically there wouldn't be a reason
for him to grab Miles Morales
but Miles Morales is a spider person and
very capable in his abilities and so
using him to his own to his own ends
that allows him to basically go against
spider-man and the rest of the
superheroes a little more well-armed
than he was before instead of just
relying on a huge amount of forces for
him to use it as disposal now in reality
like for the most part in comparison to
earth superheroes numbers Trump's powers
almost all the time the only exception
you get with that era like characters
who can like warp reality or who have
powers that have a huge area of effect
right a huge AoE
so like if you're talking about somebody
like storm who can control like all the
well the numbers don't really matter
right because she's just like you get
lightning and you get lightning and you
get lightning
everybody gets lightning you know we're
as it was some like Ice Man he can just
like freeze a ton of people at one point
but somebody like Wolverine it's kind of
like hack and slash his way through each
individual person right so like you know
numbers for the most part will trump
people with huge amounts of abilities
that's why stories like this are always
kind of intriguing but Eddie Brock has
to essentially leave Miles Morales
behind right but this is kind of a funny
thing is because the simian sort of
starts to turn now this is what I love
about Donnie Cates handling of the Venom
symbiote right the fact that Donnie K is
sitting down and he's writing the simian
in a way towards his own distinct
character this is why I say I think
Donnie Cates run on venom will turn out
to be one of the greatest runs on venom
ever written right on because you look
at it and it's like okay so you get
these these cool progressions things
like that but the idea of Eddie Brock in
the simian fighting against each other
in the sense of the Simbi it's just like
we need to kill as many of the forces of
carnage as we can and that includes
Norman Osborn and his response is no we
can't kill him because he's not under
it's not under his control right he's
operating under what what carnage wants
him to do not what is that he wants to
do and the response to venom is it
doesn't matter and that's kind of the
you know I kind of saw it with venom on
this one but I mean I'm curious which
side you go with but I'm honest I side
with venom on this one like sure he's
about operating of his own accord but it
doesn't make him any less dangerous
right it doesn't make him want to kill
them any less right I mean he's like his
desire is to kill them like to take them
over incorporate them into into the the
carnage symbiote and then to kind of
expand their numbers right like knowing
that he's not able to operate under his
own accord
it doesn't matter right like he still
wants to take them out and so that's why
it's kind of like you know you do what
you got to do right people who win wars
or one is willing to do whatever it
takes to win the war not the ones who
take the high ground right so it's it's
it's kind of cool right like you got to
fight fire with fire
the Allies against the Germans for
example right like both sides killed and
then we saw how that worked out so it's
a it's it's it's cool when it comes to
this because what is up happening here
is Eddie actually tries to turn his back
on the Venom symbiote for a minute
because the symbiote goes in and tries
to kill Norman Osborn and the responsive
Eddie is you can't like if you really
want to kill them fine go on ahead and
do it like I want a head like I'm gonna
go save somebody like I'm gonna go be a
hero and this is interesting because
what it does is it hits the symbiote in
a way to where it basically has this its
own moral struggle and that's what I
love about this is
cuz the the Symbian is now as much of a
person as Eddie Brock is right the CVS
and a spot worse like okay yes like
Norman Osborn can't operate of its own
accord
basically he's doing what the what the
carnage symbiote tells him to you know
it's part of the the Grendel and all I
kind of cool stuff he's not operating of
his own will and yes he still wants to
kill us but it's killing him the right
thing to do and ultimately like venom
settles on the fact that he does it does
not believe it's the right thing to do
and in turn ends up rebonding to Eddie
grabbing a Mac Gargan grabbing scorpion
whose spine was broken by the forces of
carnage
and then fleece basically takes off and
goes back to Rex Strickland's safehouse
which is of course again where Eddie
Brock is operating out of now again
remember like when this whole thing went
down
basically Eddie Brock told spider-man to
get out of there and like to go find the
Avengers right to like bring the
Avengers together and so of course
that's exactly what Spiderman did now of
course we get Wolverine and we get
Captain America to old school members of
the New Avengers when Brian Michael
Bendis wrote them we also end up getting
a Ben Grimm who again is a heavy hitter
and it's kind of what they need and then
we get the mind of Bruce Banner and the
reason why they need them or why they
need him is because when it comes to
human biology for the most part like you
do kind of have a hierarchy right I mean
you got Reed Richards valaria Richards
Doctor Doom at the top who trade like
the number one spot depending on who's
right in the story and then you kind of
start going down from there but just
because someone is like the third
smartest person in the world does not
mean their overall the third smartest
person Reed is the smartest person in
the world across the board that's true
but when it comes down to like
specializations like Bruce Banner takes
the cake when it comes to human biology
especially gamma radiation and so he's
the guy that kind of takes that takes
takes that stance when it comes to
technology
it's Tony Stark I guess it's these these
cool little things that you kind of see
with these specialization of characters
that can sort of lend themselves to
telling a particular type of story and
that's what's been going on here is that
the the science behind the maker in
terms of curing the son of venom of his
codex works right like the Codex is now
gone from the son of venom arms are gone
from another son of it I'm gone from
from Norman from from the son of of
Norman Osborn
and so basically I'm sorry the grandson
of Norman Osborn but it works for that
for the purpose that it served because
what it means as this technology can be
used to basically cure all the various
superheroes of their codices now what it
does is it removes one half of the
reason why venom would wear white
corners would want to take them right I
mean if these various characters have
been hosted the Venom's to be into some
form or another
and the codices was left behind on them
then in turn like Connors would want to
take them in order to get that codex
where that codex being removed now
carnage doesn't have a reason at least
as far as that goes to take them but the
power and the knowledge of Captain
America the power of like Wolverine the
power of Ben Grimm would still serve as
an asset meaning carnage could still
take them if he chose so again like is
there there's still motivation there for
him to basically capture these guys and
snatch them up and run away and so as a
result of this you basically end up
having you know having these different
guys kind of thrown into these tubes of
sorts that are designed to basically
remove this codex from them now a really
cool moment happens here because when
this takes place spider-man walks up
starts talking to Eddie Brock and it's a
really sort of heart-to-heart
conversation and this is interesting
because what it shows is that there
aren't really any hard feelings between
Peter and Eddie Brock right and indeed
there really weren't I mean ultimately
it was Eddie that kind of came down to
constantly tracking down and constantly
want to take out Peter
ah but at the end of the day it's one of
these things where they're basically
allies and this is why stories like this
are so cool it's because what it means
is that going forward Eddie Brock could
become and probably will be a tried and
true good guy right like I wouldn't be
surprised if you sort of seeing Eddie
Brock I'm more like Avengers stories
different things like that because of
how capable he is and because of the
fact that he's essentially turning over
a new leaf the issue with this is that
when Peter basically asked ask Eddie are
you gonna tell Dylan about the fact that
you're basically his father that Eddie
for an instant seems to not know and
then Ponder's it and then in turn the
real Eddie comes running up out of
nowhere he's I do Peter get away from
that guy only for us to find out this is
not Eddie Brock this is carnage and it
is amazing
I love these twists and turns man I love
what Donnie Cates is doing with this new
Donnie Cates man this guy I swear to god
man this this guy's like right up here
with Hickman for me like the writing
style is totally different the ability
to create epic stuff exactly the same
like it's it's amazing you're Donnie
Cates man everything this guy writes is
gold like it's it's oh my god it's
incredibly nuts I guess it's Donnie
Cates kudos to you man
I am diggin what I'm loving what you're
laying down man this this is awesome
because in turn like carnage basically
summons all of his forces in and starts
attacking every single one of these guys
and the response of
like look like like I told you what
would happen I told you we had to take
these guys out I told you we had to kill
them and I told them what would happen
if you were a half-measure
if you didn't do what needed to be done
in order to win and that's ultimately
the coolest thing about this is this
like those who can't do what needs to be
done in order to win lose and that's
just the way it is it's always that way
right like you know it's it's it's it's
cool to take the moral high ground and
it makes you feel good at the end of the
day but at the end of the day you lose
and that's just the way it is so I guess
if you're okay with losing then the
moral high ground is fine if you're not
okay with losing then do what it takes
to win and that's the response to venom
if you're not willing to do what it
takes if you're not strong enough to do
what it takes then I will find someone
who is I will find someone who's strong
enough to be able to take this threat
head-on and not have any reservation
about killing the various forms of
carnage that are running around out
there and so in response to this the
Venom symbiote abandons Eddie Brock and
bonds itself to Bruce Banner following
that like hardens is kind of like I
don't know who this loser is whatever
who cares let's focus on the things need
to be focused on but instead he
basically craps his pants when he's when
he comes face-to-face with what I think
is probably one of the most cool
characters that we've ever seen in the
history of comics venom Hulk okay for
those of you guys who are watching this
video and who are a fan of the boys you
are going to see that video later on
today that one is like three or four
issues this one's a one-shot so I'm
having my editor work on this one first
and then send the boys out later on
tonight so don't worry you know the
unser servers will be on patreon today
and the censored version of course will
be out on YouTube so I haven't forgotten
about you not leaving you hanging but
any event so absolute carnage the
immortal Hulk this is a really really
cool story that goes into why it is that
venom merged with with the Incredible
Hulk right because remember when it
comes to venom merging with the Hulk and
really in more recent years it's usually
one of these things where you kind of
give permission right where's kind of
like I'm willing to bond with you and so
when venom successfully wanted to the
whole really kind of the background
question was like why did the hawk let
it happen and what this does is it
basically explains that but it's
actually al Ewing building on some
pretty big things here it really goes
into the notion of like the one below
all and no the symbiote God and this is
pretty significant and probably one of
the biggest comics are one of the most
important comments is gonna come out
right so that's why um for those you
guys who are new to comics when you come
across a story you like it's always
important to at least skim the tie-ins
for different events that are going on
because a lot of times like tie-ins for
the events will be really really
big right I mean we saw it with like
original sin and Jonathan Hickman's of
vendors and New Avengers you learned
that Captain America was originally part
of the Illuminati and you had to know
that if you were going to understand
everything that came after right so just
small little things like that small
little moments like that this also
actually kind of has a pretty big
explanation that comes in it as well but
what it does is it initially picked up
with Bruce Banner kind of in this dark
room now in reality this is Bruce Banner
inside of his own mind which is
something to kind of point out here but
it's cool the way this goes down because
occasionally we see this in Marvel
Comics you see that like Bruce Banner is
is having like some kind of internal
conflict or he's having some sort of
discussion with himself like with the
Incredible Hulk or something like that
and it's been depicted in different ways
I like the idea of him basically being
in like a big black box right because
it's just sort of the inside and the
darkness of banners mind but of course
he's basically speaking to somebody off
handle and simply saying hey look like
me we should talk about how I got here
and now initially I expected this kind
of be like a run over of everything
we've seen with regards to immortal
immortal Hulk so far but we don't get
that and it's one of the great things
about a Ewing writing right like a Ewing
does not usually retread water if you
see kind of a recap of something that
happened before it is because within
that recap is something that you didn't
know before and so it's a really really
cool little thing here because what it
does is it picks up with the events
between the immortal Hulk the issue that
we lost covered in the issue before that
right so like basically between his
conclusion and what we end up getting is
of course Bruce Banner waking up in this
hotel room out in California for those
guys who were following that story when
he comes to there's a couple different
things that we get here the first thing
he does is he talks to like the Venom
symbiote at more or less as it is who it
is that he's addressing and he simply
says like when you bond to a host you
know everything the host knows right
like you're awake 100% of the time when
the host is sleeping you're awake when
the host is awake of course you're awake
but you don't really forget anything he
says with me as the Incredible Hulk
whenever the Incredible Hulk comes out
or any version of the Hulk I don't
remember anything i black out now that's
kind of a really really big explanation
to offer here because what it does is it
is a basically shows Banner does not
know what the Incredible Hulk does and
over the years and Marvel Comics that's
been kind of waxed and waned and played
with by various writers right like some
writers will say The Incredible Hulk
always knows what what banners doing a
banner always knows what the Incredible
Hulk does and it can be a little bit
frustrating because what it does is it
kind of creates a situation where you're
kind of asking the question if banner
doesn't know what the Incredible Hulk
does then why is it like three years ago
in the story there was written by the
about the Incredible Hulk the banner
knew what the Hulk was doing when he was
going about and engaging in his own
action
and it kind of works that way right like
if you go in you look at world breaker
hawk for example Greg pack really seemed
to pitch the idea in such a way that the
Incredible Hulk was able to reach that
higher level of power because he and
banner were kind of in agreement with
each other that the Illuminati have to
pay for the suffering of everything that
went on
you can also interpret it as banner was
never part of the equation he had no
idea what was happening but banner
references the events of world war hulk
any references like some of the things
he did right so it gets kind of crazy in
terms of how all this sort of fits
together but the big takeaway is that at
the moment right now in the immortal
Hulk stories whenever the hole comes out
banner blacks out and doesn't know what
the Incredible Hulk was doing and so
following that you know where he
basically sits down and watches the news
broadcast about the you know that mass
grave that was dug up at a military
graveyard what it does is it asked the
question is general Thunderbolt Ross a
person who's been dug up but his behind
his body been taken and says that was
initially the kind of question that was
there was asked here by banner and it
was if that's the case and thunderbolt
Ross's body isn't there anymore then
should I tell Betty Ross right like the
daughter funderbolt Ross issue with this
is that Betty in her heart before I'm
really in her inner inner Red Hulk heart
before she's so far removed from the
person that she was before
she can turn back into Betty but she
doesn't want to but she doesn't want to
be that human part of herself she's so
far removed from that from the person
that banner knew they doesn't know how
he how she's gonna react and in fact
when he talked to Jackie McGee the
reporter that today are this kind of
following everything that's going on and
really sort of an ally of vanarin
and the Hulk at the moment she says the
same thing you don't know how she's
gonna react she could freak out and like
destroy you or she could want to know
there's no real way to know here and
you're really kind of taking a risk with
regards to everything sort of popping
off and so as a result of that when he
basically spills the beans and tells her
he's kind of like how long could it take
you to get there like do you want to
know she says well it would take me 10
hours if I flew alone with you I don't
know it would take too long and we would
be seen so he basically says fold me up
write essentially kill me fold me up and
then like let me go on when that happens
the Incredible Hulk will manifest you
know after some time if the you know
with incredible knowing what's going on
the Hulk will manifest and when that
happens of course my body will be healed
because of the healing factor of the
Hulk and everything will be fine and so
ultimately they end up flying out to
this this place in North Jersey to find
the body of Thunderbolt Ross being there
and it's kind of a crazy thing because
you end up finding out that what he
ain't what the federal government had
done is as soon as this mass grave more
or less was dug up that Thunderbolt Ross
his body was taken as it was kind of one
of these things worse like is this body
out there preparing to be used by
someone are they going to resurrect him
you know and that's one of the things
that banner says is that for those of us
who were game of mutates we never really
stayed dead right like
always usually end up coming back in
some form or fashion now with the
Incredible Hulk it's easy and it makes
sense if somebody goes to shoot or kill
the physical form of Bruce Banner The
Incredible Hulk will manifest in an
instant basically he'll banner from his
wounds and then go on a rampage but for
other characters they really always seem
to kind of make some sort of return even
if they lose their power stand up giving
their powers back somewhere along the
line now it really is kind of value and
kind of communicating with this how like
writers treat mutates treat like you
know mutates like they always come back
some writer always brings them back
somewhere along the line or something
like that but even within Marvel
continuity they always end up making
their return as it was kind of a cool
moment it's kind of a cool little thing
there because following that it is the
Incredible Hulk saying okay if this is
the case then like we have to somehow
figure out what's going on with venom
like how venom ties into this and all
that kind of good stuff right and so
when that happens like when that goes on
when the Hulk is watching the police
investigate the site they say the reason
why it was dug up is because there was
basically a younger guy by the name of
Angelo Fortunato who we've talked about
in our videos on all the Verge's
versions of carnage and venom and so on
who ultimately had a venom symbian right
so venom in early saw you know carnage
will or venom or somebody hosting a
symbian is involved in this which breezy
Incredible Hulk to kind of confront and
figure out what's going on and so inside
Bruce banners mind for a second I want
to talk about this he's in he's met by a
couple personalities the first one is a
personality of Joe fix it and it's kind
of cool to see a version of Bruce Banner
and his Joe fix-it form right because
you never really see that you never
really see banner when he's Joe fix-it
into Joe freaks of personality all you
ever really see is great hulk and it's
cool to see like the human form of great
Hulk right like how does that
personality manifest this is also kind
of a big deal as well because when you
look at the versions of Bruce Banner you
look at the verses of the Incredible
Hulk
all you really see is that you've got
like banner as as a singular personality
and then like all the other
personalities are incredible hulks but
inside the mind of banner is basically a
whole bunch of banner personalities that
can turn into their own versions of the
Incredible Hulk
it's cool is it's a really really cool
bit of a revelation here you know it
seemed kind of like a version as your
fixer that looks like banner it's kind
of Awesome you know it's a pretty cool
little thing to show now you've also got
like The Incredible Hulk who shows up
kind of you know offers his own little
tidbit here it's kind of like it hurt
like hell to get crumpled up like that
it's a small little thing but ultimately
you know this journey of banner or I
guess of Hulk and banner trying to
figure out what's going on with venom
and how he ties into all this
leave them into confronting spider-man
now of course this little segment of the
story takes place during absolute
carnage when spider-man leaves Eddie
Brock to go find the Avengers rifle as
you guys who were following
that story and with banner running into
him and basically saying hey looked like
we'd have a conversation
tell me about venom tell me everything
that you know about venom basically like
like finally I kind of recaps carnage
you know the events of absolute carnage
and says like essentially could his
Cassidy's back in all hell's breaking
loose and there's this guy Knoll the
symbiote god he's some kind of a cosmic
Satan and this immediately resonates
with Banner and this is when we started
to get into the what seems to be the
relationship which we know all the
symbiote god and and like the one below
all because to refer to null as a kind
of cosmic Satan for spider-man to do
that drives banner to basically say like
it makes me think of the one below all
know the semi of God has some kind of
affection simile or is like is basically
the one below off but in a different
form and here's the thing that's
entirely possible take for example the
character of the fulcrum in Neil
Gaiman's Neil Gaiman's Sandman comics
now sorry not saying man US Allah not
Celestials Eternals comic there we go
the fulcrum is this being that kind of
resides at a bar this sort of like where
were Celestials go when they basically
die like when they pass on and the
fulcrum is this this astronomically
powerful being but you don't know
anything about him
the only real sort of indication you
have is in those eternal stories itself
where it's like he might be like an
aspect of the one above all and even
then it's just sort of guesswork right
there's nothing that definitively says
here is what the fulcrum is and here
like the Volcom doesn't say like oh I'm
just an ass back to the one above all is
basically all I am like I'm just kind of
here to hang out you never get that it's
just kind of left to believe that's the
case but like that happens right at
least cosmic beings eat these super
powerful entities creeks kind of like
fetch similes of themselves or work
through individuals and that's how
banner sort of perceives this in his
mind
no the symbiote God and this is entirely
possible nova symbiote god is either a
being being worked through while by the
one below off or it is an aspect of the
one below off no maybe an aspect of the
one below off but it's autonomous he can
go out and do his own thing he owes own
motivations but he he possesses a
fraction of the power of the one below
wall or the one below walls working
directly through him and saying like
like controlling him
that kind of a thing but because of the
relation between the two the question is
asked like how does all this tie
together and that's why Bruce Banner
ended up allowing himself to be bonded
with the Venom symbiote at the end of
the most recent absolute karna storyline
because banner wants to know are the one
below all and all the same thing are
they two different beings is a
coincidence is it really just Peter
Parker ran off a name and banners
reading too much into it we don't know
but Al doing is really kind of teasing
the idea that like they're somehow in
cahoots or related to one another or
somehow the same beam as it was a really
cool thing because what it does if
that's the case then it could be a
scenario where we're literally the one
below all has all different kinds of
fact similes that are out there all
different kinds of version of themself
that exist all throughout the entirety
of the multiverse right because if the
one above all is the supreme creator the
top being of the multiverse then the one
below all would be like at the very
bottom of it all but like he's a
multiversal entity as well it's cool and
it's a really interesting idea because
it kind of goes forward like asking the
question how close are they how involve
are they I'm excited to find out like I
really want to know it's a cool thing to
tease and I'm really excited to see the
answer for it okay so we are continuing
our coverage on weapons Plus and here's
a funny thing about this right weapons
Plus is probably the most important
comic book that Marvel is releasing
right now that no one's reading and it's
kind of a shame because there's so much
going on in in this whole weapons plus
comic and here's my bet I would bet all
the money in my pockets - all the money
in your pockets that this is all going
to go towards the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in some form or fashion
what other reason is there to release
and basically revamp the entirety of
weapons plus if it's not going to be
incorporated into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's gonna make any sense right
because nobody was really asking for and
that's one of these we talked about in
the first video nobody was really asking
for like a revamp of weapons bus just
came out of nowhere now Marvel could be
doing it of their own volition but I
feel like this is gonna be a model
cinematic universe kind of thing but the
idea behind this and in the first
weapons Plus it we had talked about it
and this this one of the things that
kind of came out of this is weapons Plus
was historic leaves it was it was kind
of a weird thing right now
weapons Plus was originally just a
Wolverine thing and that was really all
it was then it turned into with with
Grant Morrison's run it turned into
weapon one which was Captain America
running all the way up to web and X
which is Wolverine and that's when the
official weapons Plus program came to an
end unofficially it continued on while
you got Deadpool you got the The
Stepford cuckoos with you know there
were basically clones of Emma Frost you
got all kinds of stuff that came after
came after will rank but the officially
sanctioned weapons Plus program as it
was operated as a joint venture between
Canada and the CIA was basically
disbanded like it was essentially gone
and so the funny thing about this and
what this did at least in the the first
the first video that we did is it
basically established that weapons Plus
was alive and well Ryley it was commit
was keeping on keeping on and the extent
of it we didn't know and
still don't know but the crazy thing
about this is that that what it does is
it basically has like this weapon v
facility right this and it's interesting
you could call it weapon five and that
really kind of seems to be the case it's
sort of seems to be like a dual meeting
between weapon weapon you know five and
like weapon venom but what it does here
is it basically says okay essentially
like during the events of absolute
carnage when you know cletus kasady and
his various mini counterparts more or
less we're kind of terrorizing
throughout the city of New York and
attacking various places that what
Cletus Kasady has also been doing is
striking at the heart of these various
facilities because remember the overall
theme behind absolute carnage as a
Cletus Kasady is going after anybody
who's ever won a symbian right because
anybody who's ever wonder Cindy it gets
this kind of codex that's basically
bonded to their genetic material and in
turn Cletus Kasady in order that
increases strength to become this wildly
powerful being for what seems to be the
purpose of going toe-to-toe with Knoll
the City of God all really seems to be
rooted in this idea of gaining like
these these codices right these little
codices that have been bonded to people
and so what ended up happening is
somewhere along the line he attacked
this Weapon 5 facility now what this
does is it jumps directly to Clayton
Cortez now here's thing about Clayton
Cortez right I would say about a year
ago Greg Pak had this really really cool
idea that marveled is kind of wasted and
the idea behind this was to essentially
introduced something called weapon age
now weapon age was a cool idea like when
it first popped up it was a cool idea
but like I was always I was considering
covering it the problem was I was
looking at the entirety the Marvel
landscape at the time and as soon as I
saw that come out my immediate thought
was Marvel is not gonna do anything with
that and the reason why is because what
it ended up turning into his marvelous
grand reshuffling right so it was like
during like the old you know damn slot
spider-man 1 when Peter Parker went back
to being spider-man and it lasted like
12 to 14 issues and then we got Secret
Wars so it was like okay so Peter
Parker's back but none of its gonna
matter because we're basically getting
Secret Wars so you're gonna have to wait
until Secret Wars is done to see what
happens with all of this of course and
we end up getting all-new all-different
amazing spider-man and so on but you
know looking at this I was like okay
I've seen this a million times right
like some character is introduced
basically it like the the the precipice
is what's gonna be like a huge
reshuffling at Marvel and usually Marvel
ends up wasting them and that's what
they did here and they wasted Clinton
Cortes the idea behind this is that
William Stryker had his own kind of
weapons Plus program going on not not
tied into like the overarching weapons
plus thing but basically his own sort of
weapons weapons Plus idea and that was
really predicated on the notion
we gotta kill mutants so what does use
weapons press technology in order to do
it and so what ended up happening is is
William Stryker gathered together at the
genetic material of essentially the
entire x-force team at the time and then
in turn had them all bonded to Clayton
Cortez now there was Weapon beta and
then Weapon alpha or at least Weapon H
beta and Weapon H alpha or whatever you
want to call it H beta H alpha it was
kind of a weird thing but the idea
behind this is that Clinton Cortez is
basically Weapon alpha weapon H he was
the prime version and this is a guy who
essentially has adamantium bonded to his
skeleton he's got the incredible whole
concept Rights was not unlimited
strength but it is like an insane amount
of strength and then he's also got
Wolverines claws right so he's a merger
between two of these characters along
with some other characters too right
like domino different things like that
and this it's an amazing idea like it is
it is a super cool idea but Marvel be
Marvel wasted I imagine as time goes on
he may become more prominent but the
reality is that weapon H is largely just
a Greg Pak concept that's really all in
it but it's just only Greg patch thing
and so as a result of this it's kind of
crazy feels you guys who are new to
comics want to talk about this for a
second so those are guys who are new to
comics Marvel Comics operates very
similar to like the WWE from wrestling
you have a character who hits their peak
usually the championship belt and then
for the most part they just kind of fall
to the wayside to make room for the new
guys and that's basically what happened
with Greg Pak he's an incredible writer
and amazing writer but the idea here is
that he basically peaked for lack of a
better word with his run on the
Incredible Hulk but because it was
selling so well what was kinda like do
your own thing man so he just sort of
gets shuffled off to no man's land but
has total control over what he wants to
do right so he's like to Starling with
the infinity saga but the idea here is a
Clinton Cortes you know some six minutes
into this video the idea is that Clinton
Cortes ends up arriving back at his
family home where at least where his
family's kind of residing at now this is
an important thing and the reason why is
because after he became Weapon Age and
after he fought the Incredible Hulk
Wolverine and then essentially left them
and went to go do his own thing he
started going from eaglestar facility to
eaglestar facility and essentially
wiping out all the records of himself
the reason why this matters is because
eaglestar was the the group that clinton
was part of before he was forced into
Weapon H an eagle spar was basically
just kind of like this military
contracting team right these guys would
just go out and take care of these
various schemes and that's actually
where you end up getting into this this
little segment is that you end up in
this scenario where Clayton's basically
confronted with like his old boss where
it's like we were supposed to wipe out
the whole village you didn't so forth
you know in a search though they're the
base
we capture him there there to like to
grab him and bring him in and the reason
for that comes by way of a guy named dr.
Andrew Breen
now we'll talk about Andrew Breen here
in a minute because at the moment he's
just kind of there any becomes more
important as the story goes on or at
least once we get towards the end but
what he does is kind of give us this
timeline of weapons Plus and this is a
very important segment here and the
reason why is because in the first video
is kinda like okay here's the timeline
of weapons Plus based on what we know
and what this does is essentially clear
all that out and the cool thing about
this is it really kind of goes back to
what we originally talked about right
this idea that what you had in the early
days is you basically just kind of had
this idea that existed out there that
weapons Plus was basically the reason
for the creation of Captain America but
the problem was that once Captain
America was believed to have been dead
then the question became what do we do
next and so that kind of went into what
we talked about previously where you had
these weapons projects that were being
created weapons two and three and four
and so on and so forth but the big thing
was that in 1965 this is what we don't
what we kind of talked about and
absolute cons have sort of been hunted
up but it really kind of gets
consolidated here which is pretty nice
but in 1965 as such they shield led by
Nick Fury along with a handful of others
ended up coming into contact with what
was basically the Grendel now of course
those of you guys who were following
Donnie Cates run and those of you guys
who were following absolute carnage are
aware of this but for those of you guys
who were not the grin was kind of like
this leftover remnant more or less of
when know the symbiote God was kind of
rampaging throughout the universe right
and so the idea was that was essentially
frozen on earth and and just kind of
stuck there this led into the concept of
the sim soldiers right so the idea of
like Rex Strickland and so on and so
forth over at Donna Cates venom run as
well as what we saw in the first weapons
plus weapons Plus video and this idea
was that when you know with this kind of
culminating with Russia's Department X
which basically gave us like the Winter
Soldier it gave us the Red Room which
produced women like like a Black Widow
and Natasha Romanov and so on and so
forth because of the fact that weapons
Plus which for the most part only really
focusing on Russia when they came across
the Grindle what they realized was the
threat that's criminal host and so as
results that what they ended up doing
was basically extracting sections of the
Grindle off whether these small little
bits here and there which were
essentially you know the the precursor
to the venom Samiha and what they ended
up doing was bonding it to guys like
Rhett Strickland right so this goes into
that whole thing following that what we
end up learning here and that's what we
didn't know before we ended up learning
here is that where it was previously
believed that weapons Plus at least as
part of it you know being a kind of
government-sanctioned organization was
essentially gone the reality is that's
not the case that weapons Plus still
appears to be a government sanctioned
organization albeit operating in like a
super super deep clandestine way but
characters like anti-venom like like
Flash Thompson
he's a byproduct of weapons plus what
this is doing is basically grabbing the
entire venom mythos as it exists both by
way of what Donnie Cates is doing as
well as people before him with the
introduction of like Flash Thompson as
agent venom and so and so forth and is
consolidating all of it down into a
singular timeline and that's a genius
idea because what this basically means
is that every iteration of the Venom
symbiote has appeared in Marvel Comics
as part of any kind of military team or
any kind of specialized operations team
like agent venom has all been sanctioned
and secretly controlled by the weapons
Plus organization and this is cool like
this is really really awesome because
from there like what it means is is it
literally kind of brings it all together
right and that's that's one of the
things that Marvel's been focusing on a
lot recently it's creating more
cohesiveness not only that what we also
end up learning is that while Kirk Hart
who's basically the direct supervisor
released was the direct superior of
Clayton Cortez when he was part of Eagle
Stark while they had essentially gone
underground and they still exist as a
team they're now simply referred to as
like Mars team as opposed to like the
Eagle star group or anything like that
it's a way to kind of cast off the
previous name and then sort of operate
as kind of a blackops wet work team and
then to essentially stay off the radar
without anybody heating them up for like
contracts or anything along those lines
but the idea here is they were the ones
that were originally at the weapon v
facility when carnage first attack in
the beginning of the story and then they
basically made it out you know by the
skin of their teeth but they're
launching this attack yet again and
that's why they're bringing in Clayton
Cortez because Clayton Cortez is a heavy
hitter right like he's a big hitter and
so that's when you kind of end up
switching over to Cletus Kasady who's
actually sitting at a bus stop and the
idea here is is that Cletus Kasady is
ultimately drawn to these guys and this
is a cool little a cool little bit of a
revelation here right because this is
where the reasons why tie-ins can
oftentimes really expand and make a
story a lot more interesting the Kudus
cassidy is traveling all over the world
to find anybody who's ever hosted the
venom Samia and the fact that these
these these you know former Eagles
starter know Mars team guys are these
we sim soldiers meaning that their
harnessing the power of the Grendel
means they all have codices and so as a
results of that carnage is going after
them as well and that's the cool thing
is it's not just about super-powered
beings and it's interesting to see
because when this bus comes cruising in
right this bus comes flying in please
Cassidy of course is on it but he's
killed everybody there and this is one
of the funny things that goes on is
because what this really shows is that
the in terms of the government's
perception at least weapons pluses
perception of carnage and what is it
he's capable of now they're painfully
ill-equipped right they're painfully
unprepared and the reason why is because
all they really know about what carnage
is capable of at the moment is what they
seen in the various footage from the
from the Battle of New York because
they're not really there as well as the
existing knowledge they have when it
comes to the simius but remember the
Grindle's are cut above the rest this is
not just your regular venom Samiha these
guys are really bread and Android the
Grendel's the Grendel concept itself is
really designed to be like this kind of
uber symbian which of course serves the
the will of no Allah symbiote God and so
with carnage walking around with this
sort of power and then in turn these sim
soldiers walking around with something
akin to this power their initial thought
is okay so simians are basically weak to
sonic and fire so we'll use that neither
of which work right I mean neither of
those bring him down the carnage just
comes running out and it makes sense
right like the entirety of absolute
carnage would be kind of a bust if it's
just like so all they need is fire okay
I'll just go get pyro from like the
x-men and just watch how fast he kills
kills carnage you know like pyro shows
up and he's like somebody give me a
lighter you know or bring in like like
you know Ghost Rider or anybody who can
manipulate any kind of hellfire and they
would totally destroy carnage and so
it's cool to see that that's not the
case instead what you get here is it's
pretty knock-down drag-out fight between
Weapon H n and carnage itself and this
you know while this it's not the
grandiose thing ever this is really
Marvel just kind of proving a point and
showing us where carnage is and the
reason for that is because when you read
the absolute carnage of in itself and
you see him face off against various
characters it is interesting but you can
kind of chalk that up to the nature of
carnage right there there really isn't a
whole lot this happen that it's just
like okay so just here's how far he is
above everybody else you have really
seen a whole lot of that yet and the
reason why is because a lot of the
conflict that you've seen has really
been confined like the spider base and
the venom base characters right so so
it's big you're fine till like Miles
Morales and to like spider-man and to up
venom and things like that but these are
characters that while they are powerful
in their own right seeing carnage
against the Incredible Hulk was more of
Carnage outwitting the Incredible Hulk
as opposed to out fighting the strength
of the Incredible Hulk and so again it's
kind of cool in that regard but what
you're seeing here is a knock-down
drag-out fight between what's
effectively The Incredible Hulk and
Wolverine merged into a singular person
and carnage now again there are
limitations here right Clayton Cortez
does not have infinite strength it
doesn't it doesn't really go on that way
and then that's when you start getting
to what's going on with dr. Breen and
dr. Breen what he's been doing is that
where he's been putting eye drops in his
eyes and the idea here is that he had
some sort of you know vision impairment
or something along those lines that he
needed those for you know him series he
was wearing glasses the realities that
he's been dropping the Grindle into his
eyes and the reason why is because he
said he wanted to see the world the way
the Grendel does and this is kind of a
cool thing because what it does is it
basically says that like you've got the
Grendel out there this this Grendel
symbian thing more or less is out there
and little pieces of it even siphoned
off over the years and that's what the
SEM soldiers come from but essentially
it sees the world in a different way in
so far as is governed by a singular
ideology and that's what Breen had
picked up on Breeden essentially gone
insane really whether it says like he's
absolutely lost his mind but the idea
here is that all he sees when he when he
puts you know has the Grendel in his
eyes is God is coming right like god is
on his way here everybody's basically
going to die and it's essentially all
kind of pointing to this notion that no
the symbiote god is going to return
which makes the most sense it's really
the direction everything's going in and
and after the carnage would kind of be a
bust if like Knoll never returned right
if it was just like no he's not coming
back he's just been dead this whole time
there'd be kind of a bust right it'd be
kind of disappointing and so it's cool
to see that that that kind of things
showing back up here the results of this
is that because of the fact that Clayton
Cortez had never actually worn a HD beta
itself and because Clayton Cortez
doesn't really care right he's kind of
out doing his own thing he ultimately
just ends up leaving Mars team to itself
right it's just kind of whatever I'm
gonna leave and he ends up taking you
know taking taking somebody with him and
basically bailing out and that's
basically it right like he grabs a
step-mom and they end up leaving it's
kind of a funny thing because the
stepmom hates him but to see them kind
of reconcile is interesting but that
only really matters if you're reading
what they eat right if you're not
reading Weapon H none of that really
matters to you it's not really relevant
to you the idea and kind of the big
takeaway that seems to be coming out of
this is Weapon Age it looks like Clayton
may end up joining the Avengers but
that's the nature of right the nature of
this is that this guy's trying to go on
and do his own thing and doesn't really
want to be bothered with the rest
he kind of wants to just stay off the
radar and stay hidden and so it would
make perfect sense if he didn't if it
was just like him fighting carnage which
is kind of a cool little thing in
reality if that's the case all this is
really designed to do my Marvel is to
get you know him out more into the
public eye and get people to read his
comics more but it is it is a it is a
cool concept right because this entire
conflict was basically being monitored
by weapons plus you're watching this
this whole thing go down and ultimately
weapons plus season it's just an
interesting concept but at the end of
the day they're like we've got other
things you want to worry about namely
weapon 30 right like weapon xxx and this
is kind of a cool thing because it's
like okay so like what other weapons are
they focusing on but the overall gist
behind this is that it still continues
that kind of mystery behind the idea of
weapons plus it gets him he's a mystery
behind what's going on with it and how
all that's kind of unfolding here's kind
of a cool thing here is this guy this
this person who's overseeing it is
actually just drinking from a from a
Captain America mug right and it's kind
of a cool thing because well you do have
one of his guys off to the side he's
basically reporting to him my question
and this would be really awesome here if
it turned out to be Stiebel evil Steve
Rogers from like secret Empire that
would be amazing and be like this
amazing revelation where he's basically
rebranding and reworking and running the
entirety weapons Plus behind the scenes
I would love that okay so I still have a
head cold right my mouth rotus sore and
I've got got a whole roll of toilet
paper right basically my tissue paper to
blow my nose I've got my Vaseline to
keep my nose from drying out you can't
stop greatness son
we have pick it back up again with
absolute carnage now here's the thing
right the last thing we picked up with
this like The Incredible Hulk became the
new host for venom which was cool it's
really really awesome to see like I
definitely dug dug see in that the issue
is that it just ended with the
Incredible Hulk becoming venom so we had
no idea what he was capable of we had no
idea what it was that he could do and
the reality of this is we get to see
this play out in the next issue like in
this this particular issue of absolute
carnage but here's the thing about
absolute carnage as much as the story is
titled absolute carnage
it's about absolute carnage in so much
as he's just the villain who's there the
story's about Eddie Brock and that's
what I really dig about this right I
mean of course it has carnage and of
course he's the main villain and you get
to see like a really good display of his
character in terms of how he's handled
by Donnie Cates but in reality I'm not
really seeing anything here from from
carnage that I haven't seen before what
I like is the evolution of any Brock and
nothing really shows it better than this
moment that he has a Peter
as soon as it all goes dead right
because with any losing the Venom
symbiote he's just a guy now and there's
nothing he could do to stop carnage he's
hopelessly outmatched against carnage
and even with venom he was still
struggling right so what little hope he
had was basically gone here Peter Parker
himself the best he can do is bob and
weave and dodge carnage right like using
a spider sense to try to get the upper
hand but he can't outright defeat
carnage because of how powerful he is
now right so but the cool thing about
this is is that what you end up having
is is a really cool it's actually a
really really great reference here
what is up happening is Donnie Cates
references the jury now the jury this is
an organization I haven't heard of in
decades right in a long long time the
jury was an organization created by
David Nicolini and Mark Bagley back in a
venom lethal protector number 2 and 1993
or whatever it was that story came out
and the jury was actually kind of like
this anti-venom task force is really
what it was right so the idea behind
this was that you had a guy named oral
Taylor I think was oral oral Taylor
anyway he was a general the military his
son was a prison guard and he was
actually a prison guard at an
institution that was essentially the
wrath before the raft it was for
supervillains essentially and then it
made his escape and and Hugh died in the
process and as a result of that Orwell
ended up gathering together all of
Hugh's friends and creating a task force
to track down and try to destroy venom
it didn't succeed but it was a really
cool concept and the fact that like
Donnie caves is gonna reach back to like
1993 and say remnants of this group are
still around it's cool and the reason
here's a reason why it's so cool here's
the reason why this matters is because
what it does is it creates cohesiveness
and cohesiveness is something that
oftentimes is lost when it comes to
writers crafting stories especially
events that focus on a character that
they're taking over because so much
emphasis is put on how they perceive the
character that often times like
old-school stuff is lost and so is it's
really cool to see a writer kind of say
hey look like remnants of this old
school stuff is is important here when I
guess it's a significant thing it
matters it's awesome to see these throw
backs it's awesome to see these really
really cool moments where it kind of
hits back and harkens back to the really
the old school stories now the other
cool thing here and this is why I say
like Donnie Cates handling of Eddie
Brock I think is second to none this is
the single best handling of Eddie Brock
that we've ever seen in Marvel Comics
and the reason why is because he sits
down and talks with Peter and he says I
can't protect these guys you know I
can't do it on my own
like as a singular guy I can't do it on
my own and right now it's just you and
me and
somebody's got to protect the boys
somebody's got to keep them safe that's
your job you stay here you keep them
safe I'm gonna grab some of this jury
Tech I'm gonna go out there and I'm
gonna fight off carnage out Carnage's
doppelganger forces as best I can
this is awesome because one of the cool
things that comes out of this is is
literally like any broad gets out there
and he's just like all I hear is the
screaming of these carnage things but
it's almost a little bit of like a
reprieve right it's almost kind of like
Zim like in peaceful because he's like
the one thing I don't hear is a voice in
my head I don't hear venom telling me
what to do I don't hear venom giving me
orders telling me Eddie don't do that
Eddie you have to run like I don't hear
that it's just me and he's like I'm
Eddie Brock like I can be a hero I'm a
good guy and by god if I'm gonna go down
today I'm gonna go down swinging first
one of the coolest moments of his
character like ever in the history of
like Eddie Brock do it's so beast
because what you're talking about here
is you're talking about a guy who's
basically gone for like an arch an arch
enemy of Peter Parker who wanted to kill
him
to a guy who's now putting the life of
his son in the hands of Peter to keep it
safe and is gonna put his life on the
line and knowing full well he might die
get out there and take as many of these
carnage guys down with him as he
possibly can it's a whole sail revamp of
Eddie Brock and that's why I love it so
much that's why it's so awesome because
it's a total reformation of a character
who in reality had this coming a long
time ago I guess this really should have
happened a long time ago but it's cool
to see it happen now now the big
question a lot of people had is how
would the Incredible Hulk with the Venom
symbiote fare against carnage first
things first
The Incredible Hulk looks amazing is
venom right like he looks obese and I
definitely want to see it make its
return but here's the thing about the
Incredible Hulk
all right we're not talking about like
Doc Green Hulk right like the super
genius version of The Incredible Hulk
we're talking about what's essentially
the immortal Hulk assuming that this
falls in line with what's going on with
with Al Ewing's immortal home run this
is not the sharpest tool in the shed
immoral Hulk and end savage Hulk they're
like forces of nature just like punching
and pummeling things but they're by no
means the sharpest tool in the shed
battle tactics strategies these things
are lost on the Incredible Hulk in his
most pure savage and current immortal
form and it's kind of a cool thing to
see because when you end up having
Cletus Kasady who's been around the
block more than a few times and is by no
means Captain America but is by every
means more capable than your average
superhero he gets the one up on him like
that in the blink of an eye and it will
be really easy to look at that and say
what a waste like what a huge colossal
waste but I would say
this is really designed to highlight
just how capable carnage is that even
when you have one of the most powerful
beings in the Marvel Universe and just
sheer physical strength who puts on a
symbiote which amplifies his power even
further and still gets taken over by
carnage it's a sight to behold it's just
like wow because what it does is it
illustrates the gravity of the situation
and it says what hope do they have and
all this really begins to come by way of
Eddie Brock himself and the reason why
is because using one of the devices that
belong to the jury which I believe it
wasn't the shock right here what's gonna
belong to it but it's one that emits an
electric pulse what he does is each
handle two channels it through Captain
America's shield now people who are
knowledgeable about Captain America
shield will say okay so Captain America
shield is a proto adamantium /drive
rhenium iron alloy that was created by
Myron McLain accidental right attempts
to duplicate Captain America's shield is
what led to the creation of pure
adamantium the adamantium has founded
the Wolverines skeleton and so because
it's a vibranium alloy technically
speaking it should basically absorb the
electric shock right I mean it can
absorb kinetic energy almost all
different forms of energy it should
basically absorb that but you would look
at that and you would say either the
shield would absorb it but it wouldn't
like electrocute Miles Morales Lee's
it's not not something that we're
familiar with the answer to that
question is actually yes it can now the
reason why is if you go back and you
look at Captain America comics number 78
1954 I love being able to pull out
little nuggets like this because I feel
like people are just like what holy cow
how did this guy know about this then
Captain America comics number 78 1954
there was a character who was created
called the like the electro monster
something like that model would reuse
the concept later on when they
introduced electro in the spider-man
comics but this was a character who's
created by the Russians for the purpose
of like defeating Captain America now
EDD Brubaker's run all that kind of
stuff not really Steve Rogers doesn't
really matter the fact remains when they
go and they fire this electric shock at
Captain America shield what half the
American is up doing is absorbing it and
amplifying it back now we get how to go
with that or we can ignore and the
reason why is because if you read ed
Brubaker's run on Captain America
basically every version of the character
that we saw after the end of world war
ii was not really steve rogers and it
was not really Captain America shield
they were frozen and ice basically we
found that out in Avengers number four
so you can ignore or you can go with it
you can say well at the time the story
was written it was Captain America it
was Captain America shield it wasn't
until we got into the mid-2000s whatever
Baker changed all that so you can do
whatever you want with it you can you
can ignore to you could choose to go
with it
like the idea of going with it because I
think it kind of makes a scene makes
sense a little bit more or you can just
say the electricity passed through the
shield in shock miles my house doesn't
really matter regardless of the scenario
because electricity fire things like
that are weaknesses to symbionts and
because of the fact that Miles Morales
had previously used his venom blast to
kind of jog Eddie Brock out of being
controlled by carnage this is basically
Eddie Brock recalling that and then
using it on miles and then bringing
miles back but this is a huge moment
because we would look at this and we
would say okay cool one more ally to
Assad now they have a chance miles is
just like - we're so screwed and where
the questions like why is like because
literally like being credible Holt
taking the Venom symbiote or at least a
Venom's to be a bonding itself to the
Incredible Hulk and then it fighting
against carnage The Incredible Hulk
doesn't have the wherewithal to
intellectually overcome Cletus Kasady
physically yes but all Cletus has to do
is out think him that's exactly what
happens when that time comes Cletus
Kasady is gonna seize control of the
Venom symbiote and when he does the
venom stimulus got ivory bond itself -
Cletus and it's gonna amplify his power
even more because each time he takes a
codex he becomes more powerful and so
it's just kind of like okay so like
literally at that moment Cletus Kasady
strips the Venom symbiote off of ruse
mannered when he like forces the
Incredible Hulk to revert back to Bruce
strips of venom simian off of him
amplifies his power even more and then
essentially just kind of like no one can
stop me now and for the most part they
can't write like by that point with the
10-minute window that was bought by
Eddie Brock in order to basically allow
the superheroes to wake up from their
code X's being removed they jump in as
best they can but they're no match for
Cletus Kasady I mean he takes them out
with a quickness not only that will we
end up learning from Miles is that where
the maker the ultimate universe version
of Reed Richards at the beginning of the
story who is basically you know claimed
that he was extracting these codices and
then destroying them wasn't doing that
he was actually saving them he was
basically putting them in this great big
huge storage device more or less and so
the result is that like all these
codices are they're all cars would have
to do is break into it and so the result
is that like by all standards of
measurement Cletus Kasady has more or
less one but what is up happening here
is Eddie Brock seems to make the
sacrifice to say okay fine if that's the
case if that's where all the codices are
then let's go get them and so Eddie
Brock in like this amazing heroic moment
but he's literally going through and
saying all this he's like he's like
under all the noise and under all the
chaos of it all the panic and it all
like the fear and all this rage and
everything that's going on like
all of that I can feel somebody that I
haven't felt in a long long time
I can feel hope and so what he does is
he literally breaks into this entire
storage facility and basically absorbs
all these codices into himself and when
he does it amplifies his power up higher
than it was when he was originally venom
and then from that point he basically
goes forward and ends up chasing after
Cletus Kasady at which point the story
ends okay so we are a couple weeks
behind but we are finally getting into
the conclusion of absolute carnage I
feel like every kind of bug youtuber in
the world besides me has covered this
it's all good so so here's the thing
about absolute carnage right this gives
us the conclusion to the entirety of the
event but it's actually done in a really
interesting way and in a way that has
kind of been the source of debate among
fans and you guys will see why here in a
little bit but what it does is it picks
up hot off the heels on the last one in
so far that we kind of had this massive
fight that takes place between venom and
carnage now Donny Kasich kind of build
this or really kind of kind of built
this up in a couple different ways the
first is that either it could be like
this massive fight and this final fight
between the two or it could be the next
in a long line of fights regardless of
how you choose to interpret it though
the big takeaway from all this is that
it's really just Eddie Brock fighting
for more than just himself and that's
one of the reasons why I've always said
absolute carnage is not really the story
of Cletus Kasady trying to awaken no the
symbiote guy right I mean it is to a
degree but it's the rise and fall of it
I guess the the the return and rise of
Eddie Brock for I like Eddie Brock kind
of coming back and being like this
amazing hero as opposed to like this
villain that we've seen him be over the
course of of his time in Marvel Comics
now the big thing is to remember Cletus
Kasady strength is not what he used to
be right I mean he's much much stronger
now than he was before and it's a pretty
huge leap combined this was the fact
that there were all these forces that he
has at his disposal that are basically
going through and tearing apart all the
superheroes and things pop off pretty
fast but remember what makes Cletus
Kasady so dangerous here isn't so much
the fact that he has the crown of
symbian it's how he uses it and how he
manipulates people and that's why I say
I love this version of Cletus under
under under Donny cage because he uses
mind games to mess with Eddie Brock
right like what he's literally stood
there talking to him like I'm gonna kill
you I'm gonna take the codices that you
have off of you and then I'm going to
basically wake a wicked Knoll and I'm
gonna grind this world to a red mist
like I'm going to kill everything you
know and love and
where any broad really charms back in
and says like I don't want to I don't
want to hear this I don't care like for
once in your life shut up I'm tired of
hearing you go on about all this
nonsense at the end of the day Cletus
just keeps talking and that's what makes
him so interesting is because he's a guy
whereby he messes with your head as much
as he does when he's fighting
it's very Deadpool asked very Spider Man
asked and that's one of the things that
makes characters like that so dangerous
when it comes to facing off against them
in Marvel Comics is because you're not
just fighting them in a straight-up
battle they're messing with your head
and it's one of the things that we've
seen over and over again like take
spider-man is a really good example it's
one of the things we've seen over and
over again and we never really got a
full-on explanation as to why until we
ended up getting renew your vows by Dan
Slott is part of secret Wars when
basically spider-man revealed that he
does that because it throws his enemies
off kilter they let their emotions get
the better of them and so it's kind of a
cool thing here it's a really good way
for Cletus Kasady to kind of be elevated
beyond just like this answer the
question what if Joker became venom and
instead turns into like what if he
really becomes like this super dangerous
guy now the superheroes do get some help
in the form of like Carol Danvers and
scream and an iron fists and a handful
of others who were all basically
teleported there by cloak but these guys
are if anything just a stopgap measure
at the same time that's going on you've
got spider-man basically protecting
Norman Osborn as well as Dylan and is
really all he can do but I mean he's
holding his own as best he can and
ultimately he ends up passing out
because of the strain of the conflict
this all seems to kind of point to the
idea that everybody's being overwhelmed
all along the way but something to point
out here something to notice here is
that that Eddie Brock while he really
kind of makes this claim of like I'm not
getting baited into your you know thing
and I'm not you know I'm not getting
emotionally caught up he is because he's
totally swept up in his fight with
carnage and isn't really thinking about
the fact that like Dylan's out there by
himself spider-man won't be able to last
forever I need to go back there and save
my son instead he's totally immersed in
this fight with carnage so again really
bringing out the human element of Eddie
Brock the funny thing about this is that
Dylan doesn't need protection because
when the various forces of of carnage
start closing in suddenly Dylan sticks
his hand out and just eradicate one of
them and Dylan doesn't even know how
that happened right Dylan just passes
out as it was a cool thing because we've
never seen anybody do that before who
didn't have some kind of telekinetic
telepathic or even you know either minor
or expansive reality-warping powers the
ability to manipulate biological matter
is not something
you see every day and the ability to
destroy a Symbian in that regard is
actually pretty intriguing the only time
we've seen somebody do that is NOLA
Symbian guy it's a pretty big
development here albeit we don't know
exactly how this is gonna go now one of
the cooler things about this comes into
play when the fight basically makes its
way back to the doorstep of Dylan after
he kind of wakes up after passing out or
at least seems to and Cletus Kasady
finally reveals his move and this is
absolutely genius because what it does
is it basically seems to engineer a
situation where Cletus Kasady went right
the idea of Cletus was to gather all the
codices together in an intern awaken
know the symbiotes God let Anil do his
thing and just be there as the entire
world metaphorically burns right that
was the idea of Cletus Kasady
to inflict as much death and destruction
as he possibly can and to awaken Knoll
to make that happen when Eddie Brock
shows up here I guess when the fight
ends up coming back here Cletus Kasady
basically says here's how this is gonna
go down right like you've a you've
absorbed all these codices are out there
the ones that I couldn't get my hands on
you took those you've put them all in
one centralized location so here only
one of two things is gonna happen either
you kill me you take your symbiote back
mine comes with it you reconnect to the
hide and you wake up No or I kill you
and I kill I kill Dillon and then in
turn I reek I reconnect and I possibly
wake up all right like the idea is that
if Eddie kills carnage and Eddie
succeeds in doing that and takes his
symbian back then ultimately he's going
to wake up no where as if he lets
carnage win and he basically sacrifices
Dillon but there's a chance that won't
happen right because Eddie's got all
those those codices to himself he could
just like leave earth right jump into
some spaceship and take off leave earth
and then no we'll never wake up and it's
kind of a funny thing right it's a
gamble in that instance I so it's really
intriguing because in response to this
you know any kind of picked up on the
fact that this is what you wanted but
then he basically says fine that's how
you want to be that I don't care like
what I care about is my son I care about
trying to keep this keep him alive I
don't care about anything else and this
is cool because this is really like like
Donnie Cates kind of putting us in the
mindset of like a parent right like what
parent wouldn't let the world burn in
order to save the life of their kid
right I mean if you were a parent who
was not willing to sacrifice the world
in order to save the life of your kid I
would argue you're no measure of a
parent at all
and that's the cool thing about this is
because Eddie's willing to do whatever
it takes
in order to save Dillon the irony of all
this is that if Eddie does kill carnage
and he does take the symbiote back
it does wake up no didn't buy all
centers of measurement though from what
Cletus Kasady saying assuming that what
he's saying is to be believed that
Dill's gonna die anyway right because
nobody can stop no because he's just so
powerful but at the end of it Eddie
doesn't care he does one of the coolest
things ever
he literally pulls off part of the
carnage or a part of the symbiote
creates a sword cuts Cletus Kasady in
half reabsorbs a simian unto himself and
then in turn everybody else is
essentially cured right like Cletus
Kasady appears to die when it's just his
skeleton falls down the simian is
absorbed back into Eddie Brock and the
simian immediately starts talking to
Eddie and says dude what have you done
you've literally doomed the world like
you're reconnecting to the hive I can
hear everybody now I can hear all the
other all the other semi 'its that are
out there
Nova symbiote God has woken up like you
just woke up and all the symbiote got in
effect Eddie Brock just doomed the world
and Nola's on his way to earth and is
the coolest thing because what it does
is it sets up the next event that comes
after this and it's a it's a it's a
really really cool revelation because
the funny thing is that in that whole
attack with Cletus Kasady like any broad
basically shouts like I'm not going to
let you kill my son and then of course
he kills Cletus and so when all the
litigants he kind of settled down and
spider-man goes off to do his own thing
basically Eddie's left with Dylan and
Dylan's question is did you say I was
your son and so what this does is it
switches over to venom number 20 and
this is a really really cool thing here
because you would expect this to focus
largely on Eddie Brock but in fact it
doesn't what it does is it focuses
largely on the maker right on on the
ultimate universe version of Reed
Richards probably in one of the coolest
ways ever because the way this goes down
is is this ultimate Reed was watching
the events unfold and absolute carnage
and it's talking to some people that we
can't see on there that are basically
off panel and it's the coolest thing
ever because what they basically say is
like what's going on with this kid like
like how does all this unfold and
basically the re kind of begins to
hypothesize now this is the important
thing here is this is a possible
explanation it's not definitive ultimate
read essentially says it as far as he's
aware and the best that he can tell that
Dylan is not really human that instead
Dylan is basically a living symbian is
essentially what he is right like he's
what would happen if the carnage
symbiote if like the Venom symbiote or
any one of those essentially was born
and then took on a human form and then
went forward into the world and the
question becomes how could this happen
but if that's the case how could this
happen now one thing I do want to
sidetrack here for us
this is huge this is absolutely massive
we've never seen an instance where
anybody's ever done anything like this
before right the makers argument here is
that the venom Samia is unique among its
kind but the venom simian isn't really
like all the other symbionts that exists
out there because of his experience with
humanity and because of all the things
that it's been through he then
capitalizes on that and says look at all
the times where the symbiotes have
popped up the CMEs have popped up at a
time when there was a massive crisis
that threatened the universe or the
earth or whatever the case was but the
symbionts had to basically respond by
bolstering their numbers that's why you
always saw symbiotes popping up whenever
there was a major event taking place in
Marvel Comics and as it's a cool little
thing yet because the response in the
end the question of Reed is if the
symbian if the situation was so
incredibly dire that the symbiote
basically sat down and said okay so it
seems like we always kind of spawn
randomly but instead we need someone
that's particularly special right we
don't need like just another semi eight
out there bonding itself to a person we
need someone that's a cut above all the
rest then it basically means a situation
is that dire and as the situation is
that dire then what could possibly be
coming after earth that the symbiote
would manifest and respawn in such a way
that's wholly unique and has never
happened before to create a kind of
symbiote super soldier more or less in
the form of Dylan and that's where
that's really where Reed it doesn't
really know that like Knoll is coming
back to earth
this ultra powerful multiversal being
basically it's kind of a cool little
thing that goes on there and so what you
end up getting is the super heartfelt
moment see this is why I love then I'm
by Johnny Kate so much you get the super
heartfelt moment when Eddie starts
talking to Dylan right because it
deviates to the two of them for a second
and Dylan asked the first question that
any kid will probably ask in this
circumstance why didn't you want me and
is crushing right like it's a crushing
experience because Dylan is basically
coming coming to terms with the fact
that his father is Eddie Brock and the
question is like where have you been all
this time and if you were out there as a
superhero and you were protecting people
and you were saving the world why
weren't you saving me from like an
abusive person who I thought was my dad
only to turn out it was my granddad who
was beating on me and different things
like that
why weren't you protecting me like why
weren't you helping me and it's it's
emotional and it's raw and it's
vulnerable because it's a legitimate
question like why weren't you helping me
and and it's it's it's so amazing the
seat this is why I love Donnie Cates
venom so much because it humanizes Eddie
Brock it takes him away from like the
guy who has a venom Samir and
fights people and then he gets defeated
and the story's over it takes it away
from all that and it turns it into like
a character-driven story which I
absolutely adore and so the response he
says is I will always protect you no
matter what happens I will always
protect you and I will always keep you
safe and so there is the so the
statement is no more secrets between the
two of us the entire time Dylan keeping
a secret from Eddie Brock you know
keeping a secret from him and so it's
kind of funny because it's like you know
tell me about my mom talking about this
this leo and just the two of them kind
of bonding which is a beautiful moment
between the two and I really want to see
how that comes out and so in response to
this we jump back to the maker again
right we jump back to ultimate Reid and
basically this disembodied person who we
only really see a portion of and
basically says okay it's cool that you
discovered all this but none of this has
to do with project oversight so give us
information on project oversight how's
all this progressing and that's when we
learned that what ultimate Reid has done
is he's basically constructed the bridge
now the reason why I say the bridge is
because during Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run what had happened is
Reed Richards from the main Marvel
Universe the one that you guys are all
familiar with he constructed the bridge
and the bridge basically allowed him to
look into and even enter other universes
right it really made its return during
the events of Avengers and New Avengers
those two guys who saw that portion of
the story with the New Avengers run and
we were seeing like all these alternate
reality versions of the Illuminati that
was them just looking through this kind
of bridge and seeing what was on the
other side and looking into all these
other universes that were out there but
what what ultimate read has been trying
to do is recreate the bridge for the
purpose of getting back into the
ultimate universe now those are guys who
have a minute keeping track of Marvel
the alternate universe has been back for
quite some time in fact it returned
during Brian Michael Bendis is
spider-man two story which came out
quite some time ago I want to say year
maybe a year and a half ago so has been
back for a little while
Marvel hasn't really done anything with
it has kind of been like maybe it's
referenced here maybe it's referenced
there and that's basically it but we do
know that it's back the issue is that
Reed can't really access it so that's
the idea is to try to find a way to get
in but a way out is a way in and so what
this means is that when he constructed
the bridge while he couldn't really pass
through the dimensional rift and make it
to the other side something else did
come through which is the Ultimate
Universe version of the venom Simeon now
when it comes to the ultimate universe
version of venom it's not like the main
Marvel Universe right where the the
venom samia is an actual symbionts
basically an alien race
called the Clint our instead in the
ultimate universe it was biologically
engineered now a lot of that's because
of the fact of the ultimate universe was
designed to be more grounded and less
like fantasy sort of you know we didn't
like fantasy and sci-fi and so the way
that's played out is originally you had
two versions of the Venom symbiote suit
you had the original suit that was
developed by richard parker and eddie
brock senior which was ultimately taken
by Trask industries when they were
tricked out of their ownership of the
original Simeon following that they
developed a second version which reached
stage two now the original semi it was
destroyed by Peter Parker when he was
thrown into a smokestack the idea behind
this is that the stage 2 version of
venom is actually really cool the way
this works is that instead of it
basically avoiding Peter Parker's spider
sense and actually overloads it it
enhances strength it's basically a
strength augmentation suit it has insane
healing factor abilities because it was
originally designed to be a means to
like cure disease and different things
like that so basically the person that
it bonds to gets a ridiculous healing
factor they're able to overload
spider-man's spider-sense the difference
here is that because the suit was
originally designed for Richard Parker
the ongoing idea throughout the ultimate
spider-man comics is that it always
wanted to bond itself to somebody in the
in the Parker family line and because
Peter Parker was of course the next
person after Richard it was always
trying to try to find a way to bond
itself to Peter and would actually
abandon its host in order to bond itself
to Peter but basically what this means
is that this version of the venom Simeon
as it's been brought in by Reed Richards
from the Ultimate Universe appears to be
partially incomplete insofar as it's
just a sample of the original suit we
don't know how in-depth this sample is
but by virtue of what Reed says because
was partially incomplete the reason why
he was trying to siphon off all those
little bits of the symbiote codices in
the beginning of the absolute carnage
story was to essentially complete this
puzzle more or less to take those bits
of the codices and to merge it with the
Ultimate Universe venom suit essentially
merging pieces of the main Marvel
Universe venom suit with the ultimate
venom suit and kind of create this
hybrid suit and then in turn use that
for whatever purpose he ended up ended
up wanting to use it for it but the idea
is that Reeves always been trying to
find a way to return back to his
universe and by successfully creating a
bridge to the ultimate universe would
allow him to essentially achieve his
goal and it would allow him to complete
project oversight whatever that project
happens to be whatever its end goal is
we don't fully know what the end goal of
that project is but we do know that it
involves the return of the Council of
Reed's think
I am so happy to see the Council of
region now here's one thing to bear in
mind this is not the original council
you'll notice that because well at least
as far as we're aware it's not the
original council because you don't have
the version of Reed Richards who has
like the long beard the the three of
them who had that like the Infinity
Gauntlet things like that there are
versions of Reed here but they don't
look like the original versions of Reed
now for what I understand and I was
actually talking to amazing zero who's
one of the one of my fans who's in the
discord server before what I understand
I think I think you mentioned the Marvel
two-in-one explains the return of the
council of reeds as well as dance slots
Fantastic Four I stopped reading Marvel
two-in-one a while ago when the
Fantastic Four return under dance slot
but I feel like I should cuz apparently
I'm missing out on a huge amount of
stuff let me know down in the comments
if I'm really missing out because if I
am I'm gonna go back and read it but uh
but yeah it's cool to see all this
return right because what this does is
it sets the stage for the next big event
and that's one of the reasons why I said
at the beginning of the video the ending
of absolute carnage number five and
really the any of the absolute carnage
story was kind of controversial among
fans because some fans thought and and I
was always among these some fans thought
it was going to be like a definitive
beginning middle and end and when it was
done it was finished and it was on to
the next guy
this basically ended were they kind of
to be continued feel and essentially
this sort of continues on to whatever
story's coming next so would that be
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain and make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace alright so as
promised our shoutouts for the producers
of the comics explained videos our
patrons I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have lot of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us the
first and last name so we kind of had to
roll with it I didn't mention your last
names but I want to say thank you to you
all by the way your rob four rings
should be on their way for our honor
guard members of the Rob core for these
special patrons your custom Rob four
rings should be on their way they're
being shipped to me after that I will
have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon in your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]
[Music]